Tim Ferriss: Gentlemen.
David.
Daniil.
So where did you grow up?
And what did childhood look like?
Daniil Liberman: So the two of us were born
in Moscow.
Still Soviet Union at that time.
To a family of very known neuroscientists.
Biophysicists.
Who the family were sort of upper middle class
for the Soviet measure.
But as soon as the Soviet Union collapsed
we — with the Soviet Union, the family collapsed.
It was a below poverty type of situation.
Because our dad was born in 1925.
So in 1990 he was pretty old already —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Daniil Liberman: — and didn't have a chance
to adapt to the reality.
He always —
David Liberman: And it was six of us.
Daniil Liberman: It was six of us kids.
David Liberman: Elementary school.
Daniil Liberman: Elementary school kids.
So a complicated situation.
Both parents had to continue the work as they
wanted actually to finalize and finish the
work of their life, and at the same time somehow
survive and feed kids and get some clothes
for us and stuff.
David Liberman: It's like six of us one year
apart.
Daniil Liberman: Our mom was —
Tim Ferriss: Was a mom.
Daniil Liberman: She was busy with making
her breakthrough works in how neurons work
and the signaling system in the neurons.
At the same time, having six of us in eight
years, less than eight years.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: How did she — sorry to interrupt.
But how does any human do that, let alone
a mom?
Not to get us into all these confusing gender
waters.
But let's just say for the time being mom.
Primary caregiver?
Would that be fair to say?
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: So how did she manage both the
scientific exploration with this groundbreaking
work and six kids?
I can barely manage one dog —
Daniil Liberman: I say always.
Tim Ferriss: — and what qualifies as my
job?
So how did she do that?
David Liberman: I think that after the fourth
one, we kind of a little bit managed ourself.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
David Liberman: But still it's not the answer
to the question.
Daniil Liberman: The kids were taking care
of the kids.
No, there was a —
Tim Ferriss: Training managers.
Daniil Liberman: — grandma and grandpa from
time to time.
So from time to time they would drop half
of us at the grandpa and grandma's place,
and then took half of us with them to the
laboratory.
That's how we —
David Liberman: Spent a lot of time.
Daniil Liberman: — spent a lot.
Surrounded by the fish and snails.
David Liberman: We were surrounded by all
this equipment.
Daniil Liberman: Lasers.
Microscopes.
David Liberman: They got first PCs much earlier
than anyone else.
That's why we also were quite excited about
that.
I think that in general they were super passionate
—
Daniil Liberman: About the work.
David Liberman: — about their work.
That's what we definitely picked from our
parents.
Daniil Liberman: And about each other.
So there were six of us.
David Liberman: That's for sure.
Tim Ferriss: It's a full team, yeah.
It's a full soccer team.
So you have lots of excitement.
Maybe lots of chaos.
You have goldfish, snails, grandparents, lasers.
Sounds like a pretty awesome setup for curious
kids, honestly.
Daniil Liberman: For curious kids.
Tim Ferriss: And what did you pick up on intellectually
as a way of thinking from your parents?
And I ask that because I know both of you
for instance, and I'm not trying to lead with
this question, but pay a lot of attention
to data.
You're sort of geeks for parsing the data.
Whether it's to refine how you think about
or identify problems and then also how you
might solve problems.
What did you observe in your parents or pick
up from them when it came to how they thought
about things?
Daniil Liberman: Now that you said that, I
realized that our parents were doing those
experiments which required them years of repeating
the same stuff.
Trying to get data which would make sense
on top of their hypothesis of how everything
works.
So I guess we've been surrounded by the papers.
Piles of papers with just numbers.
Literally, I remember this.
David Liberman: They were like this.
How we call this?
Cards?
Daniil Liberman: Cards.
Punch cards.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, the punch cards.
David Liberman: The punch cards, yes.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, the punch cards.
Everywhere the punch cards.
Before the PC was, there were this huge type
recording machines with all this data as well.
But what's interesting, both of them was always
challenging the status quo of the current
understanding of science.
David Liberman: So if just someone claims
something and you cannot really prove it for
yourself with data, probably something is
missing and you need to dig deeper.
Daniil Liberman: And that's how they lived.
And they had their own discussions with everyone
around.
And we sort of picked it up as we were growing
already.
I don't know.
15ish years old.
Our dad was even older, so he needed someone
to escort him to the conferences and meetings
of scientists.
Just basically it's Moscow in winter and the
roads are icy, I don't know, five, six months
a year.
Something like this.
So he needed someone to basically help him
get there.
And being there all the time, we saw his conversations
with the rest of the scientific community
in his institute as they were just laughing
out of nowhere.
I mean just, "Oh, yeah.
Of course.
Again, Liberman is talking about the quantum
nature of the consciousness.
Blah, blah, blah, blah."
Something like that.
And we were looking at this.
It's like why?
He has some ideas and proofs.
So it was sort of a —
David Liberman: Resistance.
Daniil Liberman: — resistance to the rest
of the world.
We felt his resistance and were challenged
with this as well.
Like, "Oh, we going to prove everyone."
Tim Ferriss: Libermans against the world.
Daniil Liberman: Libermans against the world.
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so we're going to
leapfrog from that.
So as far as a next logical place, I like
hopping around because I see things on paper,
I find certain things exciting to talk about,
and then we can fill in the gaps.
So I'm just going to actually answer my own
question and I'm going to take you to around
— then we can fill in the gaps as we go.
So you're around 18 to 19 years old and you're
presenting to Russian Parliament.
What are you presenting about and how is the
reception?
David Liberman: Yeah, so a little bit of background.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
David Liberman: So after Soviet Union collapsed,
the entire population of the country lost
their savings in the banks.
Twice during the decade.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Liberman: So it was a quite harsh time
for everyone.
And for us it was —
Daniil Liberman: Strange.
David Liberman: — really strange.
We weren't able to understand how with all
the modern technologies, with computers and
et cetera, how it's all this corruption and
how it's even possible.
Tim Ferriss: That your savings could just
disappear.
David Liberman: Yes, definitely some technologies
—
Daniil Liberman: Should be there.
David Liberman: — should be there to solve
these problems.
Daniil Liberman: We had internet pretty early
and we were hackers pretty — it was at that
time of the internet era when everything was
possible.
David Liberman: Yeah.
Daniil Liberman: Access to everything was
possible.
So at that moment we read lots of the hackers'
manifestos and some libertarian ideas wandering
around the internet.
And we saw all these ideas of decentralized
type of data storage, which can be —
David Liberman: Protected.
Daniil Liberman: — bulletproof from —
Tim Ferriss: Various attacks or —
Daniil Liberman: — attacks and modifications.
Like falsifications.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
It's resilient against falsification.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Resilient against falsification.
Blockchain type of ideas before Satoshi actually
released his first paper on the blockchain.
Which was never the one word.
It was blocklike chain of blocks.
David Liberman: But BitTorrent and other type
of —
Daniil Liberman: But BitTorrent and other
type of —
David Liberman: — these storages existed
even before.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
Daniil Liberman: It is about this.
We're circulating over the internet.
So with this combination of those ideas, we
came up to a solution as we saw it for eradicating
corruption in Russia.
To make all of the governmental expenses completely
transparent.
David Liberman: Store it on the people's machines.
Daniil Liberman: And store it in the people's
machines so that none of the corrupt officials
can actually even do anything with the data.
So we are presenting this idea, and pretty
soon when people realize what we're talking
about they basically ask us to go out.
David Liberman: Shut down the mic.
Daniil Liberman: Shut down the mic.
He's like, "The meeting is over.
Thank you so much."
Tim Ferriss: "Sorry, we're having some technical
difficulties."
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: "If you could step off the stage."
Daniil Liberman: And then the guy who was
actually —
David Liberman: Who invited us.
Daniil Liberman: Who invited us.
He was some sort of a deputy for the head
of the party at the time.
At the time there was multiple parties.
Not only United Russia, but this guy came.
David Liberman: Approached us.
Daniil Liberman: Approached us in the corridor
saying, "Boys, I can see you are very smart
and all these ideas are just brilliant.
But stop talking about this, otherwise someone
will kill you.
No, not us.
We're good guys.
But there are bad people who are making lots
of money and this is against what they want."
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So now at that point, do you pretty immediately
pivot to something else?
Daniil Liberman: Pretty immediately we realize
that what we need to pivot into is grassrooting
those ideas instead of trying to make them
a top-to-bottom approach.
David Liberman: It's quite —
Tim Ferriss: Instead of being the missionaries
of anti-corruption.
Distribute the risk a bit.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: It started to be quite clear
that people in the government —
Daniil Liberman: Will never ever.
David Liberman: — are not those people who
really can adopt those ideas.
And it was another story to that.
In a week after that, they actually invited
us again to come.
And we came and they asked us to work on a
project.
And we said, "Well, what is the project?"
And they said, "Well, you mentioned something
about digitalization and how digitalization
can be anonymous at the same time.
Can you create an anonymous HR agency which
will sell seats in government?"
Daniil Liberman: And we're like, "Wait.
What?"
David Liberman: He's like, "Yes."
So imagine people who actually making lots
of money and who's capable of paying lots
of money for a seat in the government.
They are people who — business.
Daniil Liberman: They manage better than us.
David Liberman: They manage better.
They can manage stuff better than us just
from the street.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: Just happened to be here just
by chance because someone was a friend of
someone.
So if we actually invite people who did something
in business and have money to pay for the
position in government, they can do a better
job for the country.
Daniil Liberman: Our first reaction was like,
"Do you really have —
David Liberman: Price list for that?
Daniil Liberman: — prices?"
David Liberman: He's like, "Yes, for sure."
We're like, "Can you give us an example?"
And the guy was like —
Daniil Liberman: Deputy Minister of Finance
was half a million dollars.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Daniil Liberman: And Minister of Healthcare.
David Liberman: Ecology.
Daniil Liberman: I mean, Ecology was $3 million.
David Liberman: So the question was immediately,
"Ecology?
We don't give a shit about ecology in Russia."
He's like, "Exactly.
That's how the person who will take the position
will have a return on investment pretty much."
Daniil Liberman: They use all these fancy
words.
David Liberman: They'll get their money back
pretty much in a year on bribes.
Tim Ferriss: Oh.
Daniil Liberman: So we quite soon realized
that they are —
Tim Ferriss: You're like, "Well, We appreciate
the invitation."
Daniil Liberman: "We appreciate the invitation.
Never call us again.
Thank you."
That was our reaction.
But yes, that was a moment when we decided
to pivot to building our own businesses and
—
David Liberman: Making our own money.
Daniil Liberman: — gathering resources.
David Liberman: Gathering resources and then
building type of technologies ourselves.
Tim Ferriss: Then you can buy the Ministry
of Ecology seat.
Daniil Liberman: One day.
David Liberman: One day.
Or we can do other revolution or something
like that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Now at that point do you — while you're
observing all of this and it's imprinting
your young minds.
Are you thinking, "Eventually we are going
to want to build businesses somewhere else,"
or did you anticipate that you would be building
in Russia for the foreseeable future?
How were you thinking about things at that
point?
David Liberman: For us, somehow at this particular
moment, it was still unreachable.
The idea that we can fly somewhere and build
businesses there.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
David Liberman: It is only years after that
we start to be more confident in our abilities
and start to think about that.
Daniil Liberman: It was miserable the first
time we flew to United States.
Just on our own.
Miserable experience.
Very low level.
Poor level of English.
No understanding whatsoever what the country
looks like and what's going on.
David Liberman: We're trying to raise investment.
Daniil Liberman: We were trying to raise investment.
David Liberman: Was total flop.
Daniil Liberman: Miserable.
Tim Ferriss: That sounds like a hard slog
of a first trip.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So at the time then you're just focused on
building businesses.
And what type of business were you building
at that point?
Daniil Liberman: We had ideas.
2001, 2002.
David Liberman: Even before that, our first
company was an ISP.
Internet service provider.
It was kind of — we wanted to have a good
internet connection and it was super unaffordable.
$5,000 to connect your apartment.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, that sounds very unreachable
for most people.
David Liberman: Super unreachable.
For us as well.
Daniil Liberman: Especially for the family
of eight people who was making a couple hundred
dollars a month for the household.
It was unreachable.
So at some point we realized that if we want
to have such level of internet at our own
apartment, what we can do.
We can go through all of the neighbors.
And it was like what, 1600?
David Liberman: We went door to door.
Daniil Liberman: 1600 apartments in the —
David Liberman: Small district.
Daniil Liberman: — small district.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Daniil Liberman: It's quite dense.
Tim Ferriss: The neighborhood.
Daniil Liberman: The neighborhood.
Like dense neighborhoods of [inaudible] in
Moscow.
And we literally rang all the doorbells.
And the question was, "Do you have a computer?"
If the answer was yes, "Do you know what internet
is?"
If the answer was no, "Okay, let us explain
you.
Let's have some tea."
And realized you are literally sneaking into
people's apartment and starting to explain
to them what they are losing by not having
internet already connected to their computer.
David Liberman: So we pre-sold couple hundreds
of —
Daniil Liberman: Pre-sold couple hundreds
contracts.
And with that we were like, "Okay, we can
now go to the bank.
Get a..."
How is it called?
Tim Ferriss: A loan.
Daniil Liberman: Consumer loan.
Just basically consumer loan.
And we use the money to buy all the equipment
to buy the cable.
David Liberman: Optics.
Daniil Liberman: Fiber.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, fiberoptic cable.
Daniil Liberman: Fiberoptic cable.
And basically connect all these households
and people paid.
And we covered the loan pretty fast.
David Liberman: It still was a quite challenging
project.
Tim Ferriss: So I'm wondering just what you're
buying with the loans.
You're buying servers, sticking them in a
bathroom?
How was it being connected to the existing
infrastructure?
Daniil Liberman: So existing.
First we needed to — basically someone to
bring the cable in.
It was the most expensive part of the operation.
Tim Ferriss: Digging trenches.
Daniil Liberman: Digging trenches.
David Liberman: We hired.
Daniil Liberman: We hired the engineering
team.
We were lucky because the largest —
David Liberman: Hub.
Daniil Liberman: — communication hub for
the Moscow internet was basically two kilometers
away from us.
Tim Ferriss: That's great luck.
Daniil Liberman: It's great luck.
David Liberman: Because our parents from science,
we were in the part of Moscow where —
Daniil Liberman: Where most of the scientists
was.
David Liberman: — most of the scientists
were and the universities were there as well.
And that's why —
Tim Ferriss: Makes sense.
Daniil Liberman: Makes sense.
David Liberman: — internet first emerged
at this part.
Daniil Liberman: So we hired these people,
the engineering team, to bring the cable.
And then by night mostly we were connecting
20-story buildings to each other by shooting
the cable using the athletic air bolt.
Tim Ferriss: A crossbow?
Daniil Liberman: Crossbow, yeah.
David Liberman: Yes.
It's just local officials, they were bribed
by the bigger player and they didn't allow
us to actually —
Daniil Liberman: They wouldn't give us the
keys.
David Liberman: — get into the roofs and
to properly set the cables.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, competition.
Daniil Liberman: Competition was there.
Even though we had the license.
David Liberman: License.
Daniil Liberman: And by law they couldn't
prohibit us to do this, but they were not
allowing us.
That's why at night we would sneak onto the
roof.
Pretty dangerous operation of getting onto
the roof even without having an access through
the door.
And then from the roof to the roof, we basically
were putting these cables on our own using
the crossbows.
Shooting from one roof to another roof.
David Liberman: This company was then acquired
by a bigger player.
There was a significant consolidation on the
market.
Tim Ferriss: So between the ninja crossbow
expansion and the acquisition, how long did
that take?
Daniil Liberman: Two years.
Tim Ferriss: Two years.
David Liberman: Three years.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Moving fast.
Daniil Liberman: Moving fast.
Then later on we realized that what we actually
need to do is super computing.
We were like, "We are smart in mathematics.
We can build out.
We can write algorithms.
And this is something."
We'd foreseen the future of cloud computing.
Using machines in internet to be —
David Liberman: To parallelize.
Daniil Liberman: To parallelize compute over
the — this was our idea originally.
Then we realized that it's impossible to do
in Russia type of business.
And we decided that what we can do, we can
start building games.
Tim Ferriss: Now before you go on.
Was the computer science and whatever coding
experience you had, was that self-taught?
Was it school?
Was it parents?
David Liberman: Our college degree is computer
science.
But in reality.
In Russia at this moment, no one will really
teach you properly computer science because
your teachers would know less than —
Tim Ferriss: Than you would.
Daniil Liberman: If you have internet.
Tim Ferriss: If you're motivated.
Daniil Liberman: If you're motivated.
David Liberman: So we were lucky.
Because our parents were scientists, we got
PCs at our home much earlier than most of
our peers.
We got internet in our home much earlier than
most of our peers.
And we were super excited about this technology.
Daniil Liberman: We were curious, and I would
say naughty.
So we would break the computers all the time
and we had to fix them all the time for the
parents to continue their work.
And that's how we actually learn how to —
David Liberman: We built our first website
for our guild in online game.
Daniil Liberman: Online gaming.
Ultima Online.
David Liberman: Ultima Online.
Tim Ferriss: Great choice.
Curious and naughty.
That can be the name of your autobiography.
The Life and Times of the Libermen.
Okay, so you have the consolidation and then
you decide to focus on games after that?
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And what form did that take?
David Liberman: We played Ultima Online.
We were super excited about these type of
games.
We thought that this is revolution because
people just hang out there.
There is no aim or you don't need to just
kill all the enemy.
Just people hang out there.
Daniil Liberman: Sandbox.
David Liberman: Sandbox, yeah.
Daniil Liberman: You can have a marriage there.
Build a house.
David Liberman: Like Roblox.
Tim Ferriss: Second Life type of feeling.
David Liberman: Second Life, yes.
Tim Ferriss: Instead of Doom.
Daniil Liberman: Instead Of Doom.
Exactly.
We're very excited about this, but had to
play only overnight because of a dial-up connection
and the phone was for everyone in the apartment.
For us at night.
That's why we actually wanted the better internet
all the time.
And that's how the ISP started.
David Liberman: So then when we decided to
build such game.
At that moment, this idea was really not popular.
Most of the — you even can find some quotes
from CEO of [inaudible] would say, "Online
games is just a niche market."
Daniil Liberman: It will never be.
David Liberman: No one will play online games
and all this stuff.
Daniil Liberman: He actually —
David Liberman: Then apologized many years
after.
Daniil Liberman: — officially admitted he
was wrong.
Tim Ferriss: That's very, I suppose —
Daniil Liberman: Honest.
Tim Ferriss: — honest.
A lot of people don't own those things.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, he was super cool in
that.
He was like, "I said that.
I was wrong.
Now we are in the game."
David Liberman: So we tried to launch several
one time.
Failed.
Our own savings.
Daniil Liberman: Spent all of our own savings.
David Liberman: Was out soon.
But then World of Warcraft was released, and
we were the only ones who were —
Daniil Liberman: For years trying to raise
money.
David Liberman: — trying to raise for such
type of the project.
And that's how at some point.
Daniil Liberman: We got all that attention
at this moment.
And we raised our first money.
Tim Ferriss: So World of Warcraft comes out.
It proves.
It's a proof of concept —
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: — for what you are also trying
to get to in a way.
David Liberman: Not only proof of concept.
It was the first game ever netting $1 billion
of profit a year.
It was just —
Tim Ferriss: I think people outside of games
also today do not realize how big the numbers
are.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: The opening weekend for the new
Call of Duty compared to every Hollywood blockbuster
for a six month period or something like that.
The numbers are astronomical.
David Liberman: This market was really for
years larger than —
Daniil Liberman: The movies.
David Liberman: — the movie market.
But 15 years ago it's —
Tim Ferriss: It's not as obvious.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: But it was already obvious
that it can make lots of money.
So we were able to convince some of the investors.
Tim Ferriss: Investors tend to like that,
yes.
David Liberman: And we got a lot of attention,
grew pretty fast, to 150 to 100 employees
in different times.
But then 2008 crisis came and just it's all
—
Daniil Liberman: And we were not ready.
World of Warcraft, it took Blizzard, the top
game development studio in the world, that
what we didn't realize when we started, it
took them like five, six years to build a
game.
David Liberman: It's quite complicated.
Tim Ferriss: With an army.
Daniil Liberman: With an army and unlimited
resources.
And us, we were like, "We can do it with a
couple million dollars."
Okay.
We were miserable in this case.
But honestly in this experience we realized
that we can be cool in developing cheap cheat
— not cheating, but how to say?
Hacking.
Hacking our way through the challenges, inventing
new stuff, inventing how we can build a —
David Liberman: New type of process.
Daniil Liberman: New type of processes and
technologies and et cetera.
And even though we bankrupted the company
in 2009, by March, 2009 I had to fire everyone,
like 150 people in one day.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds fun.
Daniil Liberman: Super fun.
David Liberman: It was the most challenging
experience of our life.
Daniil Liberman: The most challenging experience
of our life.
And then three, four months later, we already
started an animation studio, and used all
of the ideas which came to our mind during
this period.
Like, we can actually do this and this and
that.
We wouldn't do this in the games, but we can
do this in the animation process.
Tim Ferriss: So you were able to take things
from the failed gaming studio and transfer
them over into the —
David Liberman: In terms of experience.
Tim Ferriss: In terms of experience, like
lessons learned.
Daniil Liberman: Most experience, like lesson
was learned.
We knew how to do stuff better, as we were
progressing from knowing nothing when we started,
to basically having a pretty sophisticated
production process, we immediately reinvented
the animation process.
So we basically took the guy who was experienced
in producing 3D graphics and it was like,
"Okay, why don't we change it all?
Why don't we take what you know and then try
to figure out how to make it much more efficient?"
Tim Ferriss: How did you decide on that, versus
the hundred other things that you might —
David Liberman: First of all, it was a super
challenging time.
The company was bankrupt.
By that time, we actually already were quite
successful in different stuff.
We already had a venture firm, raised $30
million to the venture firm.
But this venture firm was took over.
Daniil Liberman: By our investors of the gaming
studio.
David Liberman: And so it's like ration style.
Daniil Liberman: It's ration style, ration
style.
David Liberman: The people with the guns and
the cars.
Daniil Liberman: Literally, the security people
from the persons arrived at the office, took
us in the black cars, driving us to the underground
of the, what is it, office building in the
middle of Moscow.
David Liberman: So first of all —
Daniil Liberman: And then threatening us that
they will kill us and our family because they
know where everyone lives, unless we will
return the money.
David Liberman: So this type of business experience.
Daniil Liberman: This type of business experience.
Tim Ferriss: Hard-lined, strict investors.
David Liberman: In that moment we knew that
we needed to, with the new projects, we needed
to do something fast, because we still had
some obligations in place, which we just fired
because we haven't paid the salary for last
month.
Daniil Liberman: We tried to —
Tim Ferriss: So you had outstanding debt —
Daniil Liberman: The outstanding debt was
like half a million dollars.
And we were still living with our parents.
David Liberman: So we knew that we don't want
to have investors anymore, and they see all
this experience which we had.
We wanted to do something which can generate
cash right away.
Not —
Tim Ferriss: Enough for apartment building
basements.
David Liberman: Yes, yes, yes.
Tim Ferriss: That was enough.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Then there was luck —
David Liberman: And you mentioned was —
Daniil Liberman: — because a friend of ours
who is a famous actress in Russia, she told
the CEO, the president of Channel One, which
is like NBC of Russia, like the largest network
—
Tim Ferriss: Or one of the BBC channels in
the UK or 20 Minutes —
Daniil Liberman: Exactly, exactly.
David Liberman: That we can do magic with
graphics.
Daniil Liberman: She told them that we can
do magic with the computer graphics.
Tim Ferriss: How did you become friends with
the actress?
Daniil Liberman: Friends of friends introduced
us and we basically became super cool friends.
We were like writing scripts together for
the future movies and stuff.
David Liberman: In reality, I'm not sure that
she really knew that we can do that, what
they see, what —
Tim Ferriss: But she was very confident in
selling it.
David Liberman: What she knew was that we
fixed her internet.
Daniil Liberman: Many times.
David Liberman: Many times.
Tim Ferriss: It goes a long way, keeping somebody
online.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: So she sells — it's head of
this primary channel, that you can work magic
with graphics.
Daniil Liberman: We work magic with graphics.
And we actually were doing magic with graphics,
but for games.
David Liberman: And he wanted to create a
political satire show, which would be based
on the last week events, which is impossible.
And you mentioned usual production cycle is
nine to 12 months of production.
Daniil Liberman: South Park is actually like
three, four months.
But then they leave these several minutes
for something topical, which they can produce
over a couple of weeks, right before the episode
is released, like they are doing this trick.
Tim Ferriss: And that's South Park.
They're the fastest.
Daniil Liberman: They are the fastest.
Exactly.
David Liberman: And we invented the production
process, which allowed us to produce half-hour
animated show, 3D graphics, in one week.
Tim Ferriss: How did you do that?
Daniil Liberman: The interesting part was
we just basically disassembled the entire
process on smaller pieces and paralleled them.
This idea of decentralization and parallelization
was like we couldn't live it.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
So rather than an assembly-line type of production,
you're like, how many of these can we have
running in parallel?
Daniil Liberman: In parallel.
David Liberman: We found out —
Tim Ferriss: Were you able to borrow resources
from the channel to work on those parallels?
Daniil Liberman: No, we actually at the time
were able to borrow resources from IBM.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
How does that work?
Daniil Liberman: Friend of ours was the president
of IBM of Russia.
David Liberman: And we agreed that they would
be able —
Daniil Liberman: He was a DJ in the club during
the weekends.
That's how we knew the guy.
So during the weekends —
Tim Ferriss: Moral of the story, you never
know who's DJing at the club.
Make friends.
Daniil Liberman: They're DJing at night during
the weekends, and then he's in a suit like
a serious president of IBM during the weekdays.
Tim Ferriss: That's crazy.
Daniil Liberman: That's crazy.
And the guy was like, "I fucking love what
you are doing."
I'm sorry, can I say this?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Daniil Liberman: And he was like, "Yes.
I will give you the equipment."
And they gave us, I don't know, what was it?
David Liberman: It was around a million dollars
worth of servers, with the idea that they
will give us this equipment, not permanently,
but for some time for free, in exchange that
IBM will use the fact that this show was created
with —
Daniil Liberman: The most innovative show
was created using IBM equipment.
David Liberman: Then they gives us equipment,
but IBM decided that it's too political.
Daniil Liberman: The head of this IBM.
David Liberman: And they never even used it.
Daniil Liberman: Because the show was political
satire in Russia.
So the headquarter in the United States was
like, "No, no, no, we don't…"
Tim Ferriss: That does not sound low risk.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
They allowed us to use the equipment but never
put the logo in there.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so they allowed you to
use the equipment.
And then was the president just like, "Look,
we're going to forget it's there for a while,
you guys can use it?"
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Yes.
It was exactly like this.
Tim Ferriss: Very helpful DJ.
Daniil Liberman: We made the first season
using that equipment.
David Liberman: But then already from profit
—
Daniil Liberman: And then the Channel One
paid us like $3 million for the first season.
Tim Ferriss: That seems significant.
Daniil Liberman: And with that money we were
able to buy all the equipment we needed —
Tim Ferriss: Because you owed half a million
to the employees?
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
The first we paid the half a million —
David Liberman: We paid it in —
Daniil Liberman: It was advanced payments.
So we came to Channel One, it's like, "We
needed vast payment."
They're like, "Why?"
It was like the processes.
And we basically paid the debts.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Okay.
So what happens then?
So you have this parallel processing that's
working with your semi-permanently borrowed
IBM machines from the DJ, you make three million,
you manage to negotiate prepayments.
So you satisfy your outstanding debts to paying
the ex-employees.
And then what?
David Liberman: This was the first time —
Daniil Liberman: And then this summer was
hard work.
David Liberman: Yes.
But this was the first time when we actually
start to earn enough of our own funds and
we return to — first we return to our ideas,
that we need to think about —
Daniil Liberman: How to fight the corruption.
David Liberman: How to fight the current — fight
corruption, what type of technologies can
be created to —
Tim Ferriss: Were you guys not afraid, just
for your personal or family safety?
Daniil Liberman: We still are not.
Honestly, the part of us not being afraid
probably somehow was related to our dad was
never afraid of whoever was challenging him.
But at the same time, back in 2000, as we
finished the school, we knew that if we have
all these ideas of changing the world, it's
going to be impossible if we just stay home,
play computer games, and stuff.
So we decided that we would go to some business
trainings, personal development trainings,
fear trainings.
We started challenging ourself in developing
ourself.
And by 2005, we spent four years developing
our own internal equanimity.
Tim Ferriss: Well, let's talk about this equanimity
for a second because this is super important
and it's the enabler or the handicapper, the
lack of it being a handicapper in so many
different capacities.
And I would say a lot of the people listening
to this are going to be from the US, and fortunately
for them, they've never had the experience
of being under a political regime where people
disappear.
But I've spent a lot of time in South America
—
Daniil Liberman: Or poisoned.
Tim Ferriss: Or poisoned, or fill in the blank.
Yeah, "disappears."
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: But what you realize is there
are political regimes all around the world,
very common, where people routinely are killed,
poisoned, or otherwise made to disappear.
So the risks were very real for you.
And these are not conspiracy theories.
They were actual threats.
So was the lack of fear a lack of fear of
death, or was it a belief that you could extricate
yourself or avoid any type of really significant
consequence, or something else?
Daniil Liberman: There are three answers to
that.
A, yes.
We don't afraid to die, somehow don't.
I mean this is like you die, that's it, whatever.
B, somehow — and it actually really helped
with the bandits in 2009, when they came to
ask for all of their money invested in the
game back.
We knew that it's their way of threatening
you, and they want you to be afraid.
They want you to fear.
And that's how you are on the hook.
As soon as you show the fear —
Tim Ferriss: That's how you are controlled.
Daniil Liberman: — that's when they hook
you and you owe them forever.
And we showed them that like, "Okay, kill
us, whatever, you will never get your money
back.
In the other case, we can probably work it
out, somehow."
David Liberman: And Lawrence has this experience,
that actually if you don't show the fear,
it's much safer than if you show.
It's a little bit like with lions.
Tim Ferriss: Like blood in the water.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Blood in the water.
Yeah.
And then the third one is when it comes to
the political systems, let's say particularly
Russian political system, for the KGB people
who were actually running the country at that
time, Putin was ex-head of KGB.
That's the only thing which we all should
understand.
That's a country run by KGB people.
Yes, they call themselves FSB, but who's to
give a shit?
It's KGB.
It's the same guys who [inaudible] who were
just basically killing people 60, 50 years
before that in Russia, after the war, before
the war.
So when it comes to them, they see two type
of people who are playing against them.
It's either enemies or idiots, fools.
Tim Ferriss: Enemies or idiots.
Daniil Liberman: Enemies or fools.
David Liberman: Enemies, like spies.
Daniil Liberman: Spies.
David Liberman: Your either work for CIA —
Daniil Liberman: You either work for CIA —
David Liberman: — or you're an idiot.
Daniil Liberman: — or you're an idiot who
was convinced by CIA to fight against them
and you just fool who —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you're a pawn.
Daniil Liberman: A pawn.
So we played the pawn card.
We're like, "Let's show ourself as if we're
stupid."
And we were completely transparent about all
of our ideas from the very beginning, saying
like, "They will just see us as fools."
Tim Ferriss: Like town lunatics.
Daniil Liberman: Town lunatics.
David Liberman: And this strategy —
Daniil Liberman: Worked.
David Liberman: It worked.
This point, it doesn't work anymore.
Daniil Liberman: Officially, look at what’s
happening —
David Liberman: We know people like that who
already were in jail.
But at that particular time, at the time —
Tim Ferriss: It was just so rare that they're
like, "Oh, these guys are just crazy."
David Liberman: Because we made it transparently.
If you are a CIA agent, you will try to hide.
But if you transfer money to the biggest opposition
here transparently, write an article —
Daniil Liberman: Writing an article in the
largest newspaper, Financial Times —
David Liberman: — about that, you probably
need —
Tim Ferriss: Hiding in plain sight.
Daniil Liberman: Hiding in plain sight.
And they're like, "Oh, idiots.
They spend their money.
Okay, whatever.
We'll just steal this money from the opposition
here anyway, so fools."
That was hesitation.
So for us, the shield for us all those years
was like they believe we're just idiots.
Tim Ferriss: Incredible.
All right.
We may come back to this, but I want to make
sure I don't lose the thread.
So the graphics for this political satire,
it seems to be working pretty well.
You returned to your ideas from prior, which
is how we got here.
So thinking about anti-corruption and things
like that.
And then where do you —
David Liberman: And also, we started our move
to United States in 2010.
Tim Ferriss: You started thinking about —
David Liberman: Immediately established our
presence in Los Angeles, because of animation
in 2010, and started to move our whole attention
to United States.
Daniil Liberman: So we were like, "Nothing
good going to happen in the country.
It's run by the KGB and they're not going
to release their grasp over the country, unless
it's going to be like a revolution type of
situation," which we saw that even the opposition,
they were trying to play the political game,
and it was a lost game from the very beginning.
So we knew that the show political satire
on largest TV network in Russia is not going
to last more than the term of puppet president
Medvedev.
That's exactly what happened.
As soon as Putin got back to his position,
the show was shut down immediately.
So we knew it's going to end, and we knew
that we needed to spend all of the money which
we will make from this in order to transit
to United States.
Tim Ferriss: So two questions, and it might
seem obvious to you guys, but I think for
a lot of people listening, they might wonder,
well, why not Europe?
Why not somewhere else?
Daniil Liberman: We tried.
Tim Ferriss: Why the US?
And then how hard was it or how easy to start
to move your lives to the US?
David Liberman: In Europe, especially animation
industry is —
Daniil Liberman: It's mostly subsidized.
David Liberman: — mostly subsidized by government.
So you actually need to deal with bureaucrats
and you need to get any fighting.
The private sector almost doesn't exist.
Tim Ferriss: I would say that makes it very
hard for immigrants.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, exactly.
David Liberman: Yes, yes, yes.
Daniil Liberman: And it was always like if
you want to get —
David Liberman: If you're local, you need
to work with local studios, and they should
get this funding, and all that stuff.
Daniil Liberman: We started developing the
relationship, but even faster we realized
that in Hollywood we have all the chances.
And pretty quickly we were introduced to people
who then introduced us to the agencies, and
the William Morris Endeavor signed up with
us January, 2010.
Tim Ferriss: Early, on the trajectory.
Daniil Liberman: Half a year after we started
the company.
David Liberman: It's still a challenging process.
Any immigration is a challenging process.
It took us six years for people to really
take us seriously and to get to the same type
of level of professional acceptance than we
had back in Moscow.
Daniil Liberman: But we found our ways.
David Liberman: But at least it is possible
here, like in airport, in UK you would never
become —
Daniil Liberman: You would never able to spend
only five, six years and get into the major
Hollywood studios to —
David Liberman: To be the same, like equal
in terms of market —
Tim Ferriss: And California has a lot of downsides.
But one of the upsides is — this is true
in a lot of the US, no one is discriminating
against green, and people like opportunity.
And also California, a lot of people don't
realize part of the reason Silicon Valley
worked is that California also makes it very
hard to enforce non-compete contracts.
So there are opportunities everywhere of all
different types.
Daniil Liberman: Yeah.
Yeah.
We agree with you completely.
This is the cornerstone —
David Liberman: This was our observations.
It's all about non-competes, that they are
not enforceable, that this allow you to actually
work at Google, write your own search engine
at night, and then launch your own search
engine.
And Google cannot do really anything that
you can —
Tim Ferriss: There's a lot of free flow of
talent.
David Liberman: Free flow.
Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Which makes it hard sometimes
to retain talent in Silicon Valley, but that's
a whole separate story.
So you land in L.A., you have introductions
to people at, say, William Morris Endeavor
and other places.
What happens as that momentum starts building?
David Liberman: Yeah.
We actually had a pretty good success working
with different studios and different big names
like Jimmy Fallon, we worked on the show with
him in —
Daniil Liberman: At some point we met with
the guy who used to be Jon Stewart's head
writer, and he just moved back from New York
to Los Angeles, and was available-ish.
He wasn't for a year, but then a year later
he was available.
We took our chance to become friends over
the year.
And then when he become available, like, "Josh,
why don't you work with us?"
And we managed to convince him because we
showed him how fast we actually can produce
animation.
David Liberman: Yeah.
We realized that he —
Daniil Liberman: What we realized, that people
even like William Morris Endeavor or Josh,
even being the friend for us for a year, they
never actually believed that we can produce
animation in one week.
And we had to prove it literally by saying
like, "Josh, are you serious?
Okay, let's write a script right now, a one-pager.
You will write a one-pager joke.
In a week you will have it in animation."
And that's what we did.
And he was like, "Whoa, you guys were saying
true."
Tim Ferriss: You guys can actually do it.
Daniil Liberman: You guys can actually do
it.
David Liberman: Before that he worked at Simpsons,
before Jon Stewart, and at Simpsons like 12
months —
Daniil Liberman: Like a year.
He's like, "You're making a joke?"
And it's all really old, a year-old joke.
And with us there was an opportunity for him
to make jokes, which are super hard.
David Liberman: So it was cool.
But on the other hand, really wanted to focus
more on the technologies which can transform
society.
And plus, Hollywood wasn't really our thing.
Tim Ferriss: There are some trade-offs.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: There are lots of trade-offs.
David Liberman: No one cares about technologists,
especially that time.
It's before Netflix and before all this stuff.
No one cared about technologists.
No one cares that you are faster and cheaper.
No one cared about like who is your producers
and all —
Daniil Liberman: Divorce lawyers.
David Liberman: — divorce lawyers and all
this stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, wait, wait.
How does the divorce lawyer fit in?
Daniil Liberman: We don't know, but people
in Hollywood say so.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, wait, you need to know divorce
lawyers?
Daniil Liberman: Yes, because they know people.
David Liberman: They know people, they know
the power dynamics.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, this is good for me to know.
Daniil Liberman: There's a power dynamic of
the divorce lawyers who control —
Tim Ferriss: I picked up a new stratagem today.
Thank you.
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, divorce lawyers.
Daniil Liberman: So, in addition, we knew
all the lawyers and we started to know the
people, and we started to meet the people,
and eventually we deconstructed what the show
needed to be in order to come to a meeting
in Fox, at Fox.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So you were at that point then you're pitching
your own show?
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
So we get to the point understanding that
we cannot sell our technology, we have to
sell the entire show.
David Liberman: Package, yeah.
Daniil Liberman: We package it.
We should package voice actors —
Tim Ferriss: The Trojan horse with the technology
inside.
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
We took it all.
That's why we needed Josh, because we needed
a head writer.
That, we took the voice actors, we took the
best concept artists to combine this all and
produce a pilot, like a literal final quality
pilot, and brought it to Fox.
And who was it?
Suzanna Makkos at the time, she was like,
"Wow, I love it," because we actually knew
what she likes, who she likes —
David Liberman: What type of artist.
Daniil Liberman: What type of artist.
We engineered data, data, data.
And then we —
Tim Ferriss: Went to a custom tailor to put
together a pilot for her?
Daniil Liberman: Yes, exactly.
David Liberman: But it was also some misfortuned
time, because still we didn't get back to
power.
So our show was canceled back in Russia in
2013.
The banking crisis in Cyprus, all our money
were nationalized.
So [inaudible] —
Tim Ferriss: Wait, hold on a second.
So Cyprus, you had — does that mean that
you had moved your finances from Russia to
Cyprus?
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And then it was out of the pan
and into the fire.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And then Cyprus got nationalized.
It was like uh-oh, it's the same story all
over again.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Same story all over again.
David Liberman: It was like $6 million earned.
Daniil Liberman: And all of a sudden we couldn't
pay anyone in the United States.
No voice actors, no screenwriters, we couldn't
pay anyone.
Immediately it all fell apart.
And we're sitting there and like, all right,
are we going to do it again here?
We know everything but —
Tim Ferriss: So did you get the green light
for the pilot?
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And then Cyprus, and then bye-bye
fuel —
Daniil Liberman: Bye-bye fuel.
Exactly.
And we tried to think what we can do in Hollywood
more for half a year, a year.
But then we realize that it will take us another
four or five years to recover, because there's
no money, there's nothing in there.
We're like, "Screw it, we're not going to
stay in Hollywood.
Let's move to Silicon Valley."
David Liberman: And we moved to Menlo Park
at that point.
Tim Ferriss: Right in the middle.
Daniil Liberman: Right in the middle.
David Liberman: And also, we really already
wanted to return to our real ideas.
We started with transparency again.
We decided that we can do a trick, that we
can actually not target governments, become
transparent, but target nonprofits.
Like, why we don't see how nonprofits actually
spend our money?
It's kind of obvious.
It's not your personal money.
It's like we all together gather these funds
to make the world a better place.
So we created a transparent banking platform
for nonprofits.
Daniil Liberman: For many reasons.
We were wrong about the —
David Liberman: Ability and readiness on —
Tim Ferriss: The appetite.
Daniil Liberman: The appetite, exactly.
The appetite for the nonprofits.
David Liberman: But this was also the times
when we realized that some of the challenges,
fundamental challenges which we saw in —
Daniil Liberman: United States.
David Liberman: — the economy, actually
they were true in the United States as well.
Not only in Europe, not only in Russia, not
only in Israel, but in the United States as
well.
And we realized that even with the nonprofit
transparency, if you will look at research
of what actually donors want, you will see
it's the previous generations of donors, they
don't really want to see where is the money
spent.
Tim Ferriss: Don't ask, don't tell.
David Liberman: Yes.
It's almost the last item in the list of their
preferences, their requirements.
But our generation is younger, it's actually
on the first place.
We want to see what happens with the —
Daniil Liberman: The dynamic of thinking behind
this as for the older generation, they donate
money because it's a giveback for them.
They're like society —
David Liberman: Society gives them a lot.
Tim Ferriss: It's feeling good versus doing
good.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: And for the youngest it's
like giving forward.
David Liberman: They don't —
Daniil Liberman: We want to change what's
bad right now, and we want to see it's changing,
now.
David Liberman: And also, actually, previous
generations got a lot from society, in terms
of form of free education, almost free college
education, like 30 years ago, and things like
that.
New generation being —
Daniil Liberman: Hammered.
David Liberman: — hammered with student
debts, et cetera, they don't really feel that
society gives them much.
But they really still donate the same portion.
Daniil Liberman: Share.
David Liberman: The same share as the older
generation.
But it's just different reasons to do that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I feel like some of the
younger generations here, younger certainly
than me, get a bad reputation for misunderstood
reasons, or I should say they're misunderstood
in the sense that — and I know you guys
have spoken about this before, but if you
look at, say, previous generations' ability
to get a higher education, put a down payment
on a house and pay for a mortgage, compared
to some of the more recent generations, it's
night and day.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It's night and day.
So it's important to factor that into how
you evaluate them.
So question for you guys, looking at the nonprofit
and this and the platform, you're very good
at, it seems like, letting go of ideas, having
a light grasp on ideas if things are not working,
so you can move to something else that you
think might work better.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: That's not true for everyone.
Some people get very attached to one thing
and they want to ride it until they die, and
they get attached to things that may never
work.
And I'm wondering how you think about changing
direction, maybe "failure."
What allows you to do that so readily?
David Liberman: Data.
Daniil Liberman: Data.
Yes.
David Liberman: They will learn the hard way.
Daniil Liberman: So the first, the game studio,
we grasp, and we tried —
David Liberman: So you know that if you don't
stop at the right moment, you can actually
get to deep shit.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you can get into a hole.
David Liberman: Yes.
But also what we saw in the data is that — and
what we realized also through the experience
of game development, failure, and then animation
success, that we realized that —
Daniil Liberman: It is not always about your
abilities.
David Liberman: — your abilities.
So you can fail because of different reasons,
like financial crises —
Tim Ferriss: Like poker, right?
David Liberman: — and the times are not
right.
Tim Ferriss: You have to study the decision-making,
not just the outcomes.
David Liberman: Yes, and the statistics of
venture startups, is that like two thirds
will fail, completely fail.
Daniil Liberman: Completely fail, losing all
the money, at zero.
David Liberman: And if you will look at all
these failures, there are rare exceptions,
but in most cases what you should see is that
if your startup is growing, you should continue,
you should double down with your all attention
there, et cetera.
Daniil Liberman: If it's not, think twice.
David Liberman: But if it's not, it could
stop growing.
Daniil Liberman: And probably just quit.
David Liberman: And quit and start another
one.
It's almost like in most of the startups you
will observe —
Daniil Liberman: If we look at this purely
from the perspective of statistics, if it's
not doubled the growth, if whatever numbers
behind your understanding of your business
isn't doubled, it didn't double, isn't doubled
—
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, didn't double —
Daniil Liberman: Didn't double —
Tim Ferriss: Over what period of time?
David Liberman: 14 months.
Daniil Liberman: Over 14 months.
Tim Ferriss: 14 months?
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Why 14 months?
I have to ask.
Daniil Liberman: It's pure statistics.
David Liberman: If you look at the statistics
of just —
Daniil Liberman: If you look at all the failures
and successes, it's like a pattern.
They should basically take —
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I see, I see.
That's the pattern, is over that period — doubling
over 14 months.
Daniil Liberman: If you take all of them and
divide, then just 14 months —
David Liberman: Because if you're also not
growing within this space, venture capital
will not be accessible to you, and you won't
be able to actually raise money, use these
funds to grow further, and things like that.
So this market is actually pretty special
in terms of these probabilities, like just
one out of hundreds.
Daniil Liberman: It is going to be a unicorn.
David Liberman: — success.
And if you don't see trajectory to get there,
probably —
Daniil Liberman: Probably you're not getting
there.
David Liberman: — the right thing is just
to stop and start something new.
Daniil Liberman: And knowing that your chance
is a one in a hundred, you should try as many
attempts as possible, take more shots overall.
David Liberman: Moreover, we usually show
to the young —
Daniil Liberman: One of the entrepreneurs.
David Liberman: — people who want to be
an entrepreneurs, we show this picture of
Mark Zuckerberg or Evan Spiegel who made into
success from the first attempt.
Daniil Liberman: Dropping out from the college
and look, they're billionaires.
David Liberman: Most of the billion dollar
companies —
Daniil Liberman: It's not like that.
David Liberman: — created not like that.
It's created by people who failed multiple
times —
Daniil Liberman: Multiple times, and then
got to success.
In terms of statistics, this is what we should
observe with these things.
Definitely something depends on your abilities
to execute, et cetera.
But there are things which is independent
from you.
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
I mean I remember angel investing starting
in 2008 and seeing business models, companies
that couldn't execute in a period of time
because the technology just wasn't there and
the adoption wasn't there.
And then five, six years later, basically
the exact same company, but a few things have
changed.
Mobile phones have become more powerful.
A handful of protocols have been developed
and then boom, it works.
David Liberman: Uber is mobile phone with
GPS.
Yes, with wide enough adoption.
And it was tried, these ideas were tried —
Daniil Liberman: Ordering taxi online, yes,
for sure has been there.
David Liberman: And because of that, especially
because we really balance ourself between
sometimes when we work on some forward-looking
ideas, like not —
Daniil Liberman: Flying cars, rockets to Mars.
David Liberman: — something which is not
happening yet.
And also we work on some projects which down
to Earth, which already something which is
happening.
We know that with these projects which are
not there yet, yes there is a chance to win
big, but this chance is small and there is
a lot of timing issues —
Tim Ferriss: Very binary.
David Liberman: And you can lose just because
timing is not right.
And we, as Daniil mentioned, we learned it
hard way with game development studio.
It was really hard for us to stop, even though
it was obvious that probably —
Daniil Liberman: We were lucky with the animation
studio.
And then another unfortunate event with losing
all of the money just in banking crisis in
Cyprus.
And we stopped pretty fast.
I mean we're like, "Okay, are we going to
spend time recovering, or are we just starting
something new?"
David Liberman: Yeah.
When Silicon Valley Bank crisis happened,
we were among really small group of our friends,
founders who all this time we were obsessed
—
Daniil Liberman: With diversifying.
David Liberman: — diversifying the money
on different banks.
And everyone would tell us that in the United
States, you shouldn't think about that stuff.
Don't worry about the science.
Daniil Liberman: Can't happen.
Cannot.
Just because cannot.
And we're like, "Right."
Tim Ferriss: Surprise.
We are not immune from all the problems we've
seen other places.
All right.
So I'm going to zoom out for a second because
I like to think about sort of meta decisions
that span across a lot of other decisions
and projects and so on.
So the two of you living one life, we have
to talk about this.
I have never seen an example quite like this.
I mean there are couples who are say power
couples, but it's a different dynamic.
I mean you guys have been seemingly sort of
hive mind from a very early age.
So when did this start, right?
So you have one email address, one Instagram
account, one LinkedIn.
I think the phone is maybe the same.
David Liberman: It's connected so that —
Tim Ferriss: Right.
So I'm looking at some notes here.
So since you were born, this year was the
first time that you guys spent 10 days apart
or, put another way, not being together in
one place when you went to a Vipassana retreat.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So could you explain for people who understandably
will find this interesting and kind of alien,
how did this come about and how is it helpful
versus confusing?
How do you guys do it?
Daniil Liberman: It is confusing, but we should
understand that the six of us grew up in one
room of a size smaller than this studio.
Tim Ferriss: And for those who can't see the
full studio, it's not huge.
This isn't an airplane hangar, it's not a
basketball court.
It's like a bedroom.
Daniil Liberman: Three bunk beds.
That's how the six kids could fit in the room
like this.
And then even later, so we grew up this up
until school already started and I think until
13, 14 years old it was a situation more or
less.
And then at this moment, and then parents
also send us to school by pairs.
It was like a logistical innovation.
Tim Ferriss: It's like buddy diving when you're
scuba diving.
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
Buddy diving.
David Liberman: It was dangerous to walk —
Daniil Liberman: On the streets in the '90s,
alone, in Moscow.
David Liberman: So put together, they don't
need to walk us to school so we can do it
by ourselves and all the stuff.
Tim Ferriss: High degree of confidence.
David Liberman: Exactly.
Daniil Liberman: So they were sending us by
pairs to school, not only the two of us but
the other kids as well.
So we were a pair, Dave was five years old,
I was six years old when we went to the school
and the rest of the kids were seven.
So we were beaten..
David Liberman: But because it's two of us,
we learn how to —
Daniil Liberman: How to avoid —
David Liberman: To protect ourselves being
two rather than one.
Daniil Liberman: And then so had to survive.
It's like bonding experience.
Tim Ferriss: It's very helpful for the bonding.
Yeah.
Daniil Liberman: It's very helpful for the
bonding, helping each other through the education,
doing homework together, all the stuff together
—
David Liberman: And through this process —
Daniil Liberman: By 13, 14 years old, that's
when we started forming our own ideas of what
could be cool for us to do in our life.
And that was already a sort of social justice
type of thinking.
How can we make the world a better place for
everyone?
And starting from there we saw how no one
literally was supporting this idea except
two of us basically continued the conversation
in between the two of us and it never faded
away.
Tim Ferriss: Which idea is this?
This is the combining —
David Liberman: Transparency in government.
It was just one branch of this idea that technologies
—
Tim Ferriss: So the two of you are very aligned.
David Liberman: Yes.
The technologies can actually lead us to a
better governance and that's what we thought.
And through this experience of being kids,
first we realized that when you go to school,
all kids, they are alone.
But we weren't, it gave us a lot of advantage.
Daniil Liberman: We're always two of us.
David Liberman: We don't need to struggle
to company gather around us because it's already
two people.
It's much easier to gather together a company
like group of friends around.
Also, we realized that if I know mathematics
better, we can do it the way so that no one
would know that Daniil don't know mathematics
as I do.
Daniil Liberman: As good as he does.
David Liberman: So you can actually copy —
Tim Ferriss: Like Voltron.
David Liberman: Yes.
Voltron-type presentation.
And we learned that that's what we can do
that.
And if we weren't allowed outside world to
actually distinguish who has which qualities
—
Tim Ferriss: You can cover the bases.
David Liberman: Yes, we will be able to seem
to be a superhuman because we have both of
the qualities.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So I know you guys as an example are fans
of the Collison Brothers, right?
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
And Patrick's been on the podcast.
My understanding is they're very powerful
together, but they have maintained, they're
like, I don't want to say Batman and Robin,
that's not quite the same.
They're like two of the Avengers, right?
I mean they're superheroes, but they have
clearly delineated separate points of contact
and so on.
What have been some of the other advantages
or drawbacks of doing it the way that you
guys have approached it?
David Liberman: Even though they kind of a
little bit definitely more separate than we
do, but they did a lot of really great stuff.
For example, they were CEO and president,
they switched who is CEO and who is president
and they switched roles.
So they actually showed to the world that
they are interchangeable —
Daniil Liberman: A team.
Tim Ferriss: Tag team.
David Liberman: The team and they're great
in this regard, but in our case we went to
just in an extreme version of that, having
one line of communication.
So if you text me, you actually text both
of us and you don't know who answered this
text.
Daniil Liberman: But we can answer faster.
David Liberman: We can answer faster, we can
seems to be this superhuman.
And that worked pretty well during negotiations
of the contract.
Daniil Liberman: David honestly hated speaking
to people as he was young.
He was super not into talking to people and
I was super easy to talk to people.
So it was my role in the couple to talk all
the time.
David Liberman: And I still never pick up
the phone —
Daniil Liberman: He was never picking up the
phone —
David Liberman: — if someone called.
Tim Ferriss: I don't pick up the phone either.
For me, it's just too much.
I don't know what I'm signing up for unless
it's my brother or a family.
Okay, fine.
There are a few exceptions.
David Liberman: It mentions that you can outsource
that.
That's nice.
So that worked in business principle.
Even though our first business partners, they
were like, why you are in the same meeting,
you can be in two places at the same time
and think like that.
But we even at some moment gave up on trying
to explain them that it's allow us to — in
business especially, it's like win or lose.
You won this contract or lost the contract.
And all these meetings are important and if
—
Daniil Liberman: If you're playing two contracts
and losing both of them, it doesn't matter
that it was two of them.
If you're playing one, but you're playing
hardcore game of us being a team in this conversation,
which can win the contract.
It works much better.
Tim Ferriss: Bird in the hand versus two in
the bush.
What are your respective roles generally then
in terms of responsibilities or strengths?
How do you think about them?
Daniil Liberman: I would put this way, we
have two different intuitions and they're
completely different.
David's intuition is he absorbs data, he remembers
everything and then at some point he can just
like, "The answer is this, like, 42," just
out of nowhere, and you're like, "Why?"
He's like, "I don't know, but I'm pretty sure
that it's 42."
Tim Ferriss: 42.
Yeah, it's like The Hitchhiker's Guide to
the Galaxy.
Daniil Liberman: And then the next morning
he can wake up.
He's like, yeah.
And now I know why.
So I figured.
I cleared my path to this place in my mind,
which actually made the calculation and tell
me it's 42, so here's why.
My intuition is completely different.
My intuition is like, "We need to fly to London
tomorrow."
He's like, "Why?"
"I have a good feeling about this."
And then we fly to London and we got the investors.
It's like this and [I'm] like, "We need to
offer these people this."
And then he's like, "No, no, no, no, no."
I'm like, "Yes, yes, yes.
We need to offer them this."
I offer them this, and they're like, "Yes,
agree," handshaking.
And they're like, "How did you know?"
I'm just like, "I felt it."
David Liberman: So Daniil, much better in
the reading people, Daniil much better in
reading situations in general.
I'm much better in processing data, processing
knowledge.
I have these strange qualities that I remember
—
Daniil Liberman: Everything.
David Liberman: — everything.
All the events, all the emails —
Daniil Liberman: Give him some time and he
will.
Tim Ferriss: Is that hard for you?
I'm just wondering because I have family members
like this and sometimes it's a huge advantage,
but are there things that you wish you could
forget or is it —
David Liberman: I learned to live with that.
I think that because we have both of it and
I see what is the advantage of a different
type of thinking, et cetera, and I learned
how to live with that and now I embrace it.
I understand the limitations, but I cannot
read dissertation properly.
I understand the limitation of this tool,
but because it's two of us and we have both,
I actually doubled down into these qualities
and developed these qualities further and
further and further.
Tim Ferriss: Do you guys get physical or psychological
anxiety when you are separate?
David Liberman: This was the first time when
we were separate.
Daniil Liberman: April was the first time
when we're separate, not even being able to
text each other because the phone is off during
Vipassana.
For 10 days long in our life.
Tim Ferriss: What was that like?
Well, see you had something to do.
I mean you're in your own mind, but you had
a task.
So what was it like for you David?
David Liberman: It was unexpected, but for
me it was okay because I knew that Daniil
is working on something which is important.
I knew that if he will extract some new experiences
out of it, I also will do that.
So it's kind of I outsourced this —
Tim Ferriss: He was the Guinea pig.
Daniil Liberman: I was the Guinea pig.
And I actually felt like I had this intuition,
I got to do this and I just went and it was
so quick.
So David had to wait for three months.
David Liberman: So everyone expected —
Daniil Liberman: I was accepted four days
before the course started.
David Liberman: So everyone expected around
that I will be devastated by this experience.
But somehow I was super calm because I probably
knew that Daniil is working on something important
for us and that didn't feel like —
Tim Ferriss: There was a purpose behind it.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: And then the second time
was the same situation but reversed.
He was working on his mind and I was back
home.
For me it was a little bit more challenging,
meaning that I had this sort of a mind trick,
which was: "It's your fault that he's there
struggling there."
I'm like, "What am I talking about?
For you it was a great experience.
Yeah, but for David, maybe it's not as great.
Maybe it's challenging for him.
Come on, seriously, stop it."
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So you had the internal voice keeping you
company.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Part of the reason I ask, and
I don't know if this is true, this is from
the New Yorker piece, is “Selling shares
in yourself is the way of the future,” which
I would love to hear what they got, if there's
anything you wish were different in that piece
for those people who might check it out.
But I was curious because at one point it
says at home the brothers share a single king-sized
bed.
Is that still the case?
David Liberman: We recently changed it.
Daniil Liberman: In April, we moved to a new
house and we basically decided to have more
bedrooms and we have separate bedrooms now.
David Liberman: Because this behavior creates
some limitations, especially around relationships.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I would imagine so.
David Liberman: And so we decided that especially
now when it's published, would become an additional
problem.
Tim Ferriss: It was already right in The New
Yorker, right?
I imagine I'm not the first person to ask
you about this.
David Liberman: So in general our bond is
quite challenging in terms of relationship.
That's why we decided that we need to make
it easier —
Daniil Liberman: Like romantic relationship,
he means.
David Liberman: Yes.
We decided that we need to explicitly make
it easier for potential romantic partners.
And splitting bedrooms is one of the first
that is —
Tim Ferriss: Maybe a key.
Daniil Liberman: Different floors.
Like Daniil has his own floor and David has
his own floor in the house, so.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I can imagine those in my
mind as I'm painting a picture, I just imagine
the floors looking very different if the respective
brother floors must be very different.
David Liberman: But also when we were in the
same room, it was for purpose.
We usually would stop talking only before
a minute we'll go to sleep and —
Daniil Liberman: Start talking as we wake
up.
"So what are we doing today?
This is a wake-up call."
David Liberman: So now we're traveling to
New York, we're in one —
Daniil Liberman: In one part of the room.
David Liberman: We constantly talk.
Daniil Liberman: And we constantly talking
nonstop.
Tim Ferriss: I mean what an incredible blessing
and gift it is that you guys have each other.
Daniil Liberman: Yeah, I mean we're absolutely
enjoying this way of life.
Yes, as David said, challenges in the romantic
relationship.
We will work it out.
Tim Ferriss: So do you think when you have
romantic partner, let's just say you have
romantic partners, maybe you have families,
who knows.
Do you think you guys will still live together?
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: We maybe we'll do some is
in our vision.
We maybe can create special house when you
have sections of private and not private in
something like that.
Because we definitely need to hear also what
our partners —
Tim Ferriss: Partners have to say about things.
David Liberman: Have to say yes.
But we really want to still have a place for
the two of us when we can spend a lot of time
together.
Tim Ferriss: So I have heard, people need
to fact check this because I think a friend
of mine told me just as a model, that Tim
Burton and his wife, I think it's Helena Bonham
Carter, if they're still together, I don't
know, but that in their house they actually
lived in separate wings and then they would
come together for shared meals and things
like that.
So they had a very unorthodox arrangement.
David Liberman: We have friends who build
houses when they have joint bedroom and —
Tim Ferriss: Separate bedrooms.
David Liberman: — separate bedrooms.
Daniil Liberman: And a wing for kids.
David Liberman: A wing for kids —
Daniil Liberman: A wing for him, wing for
her, wing for kids and wing for them together.
Tim Ferriss: It's like a spaceship.
I like it.
I'm very interested in all.
That's why maybe the divorce lawyers can give
you some advice from Hollywood.
What has worked?
What has not worked?
So you mentioned Evan earlier, not everyone's
going to recognize that name.
How did you guys end up at Snap?
Daniil Liberman: How did we end up?
So our point of view, we always tell this
story from the perspective of us meeting Dalai
Lama in 2010.
Tim Ferriss: When in doubt, go with the Dalai
Lama story.
Daniil Liberman: So it was back in 2009, right
in between us starting the animation studio
and bankrupting the game studio, there was
a three months of us —
Tim Ferriss: Took a Dalai Lama sabbatical.
Daniil Liberman: Yeah, there was three months
of us clearly not knowing what to do and then
the bandits are threatening our lives.
We don't don't know how to return the money.
And then we just decided to go for a five,
six days meditation retreat of Rinpoche Tibetan
lama who just arrived to Moscow and a friend
invited us.
So we came there with no expectations whatsoever.
But the gentleman was very interesting.
He was young, he was super smart, speaking
like 11 languages.
And from time to time he would switch from
this Tibetan stories about the enlightened
kingdoms to something more practical, even
claiming that a single person can actually
change the world if they want.
And for us it was like, wait, what?
Are you talking to us?
And we then asked if we can have an audience
with the Rinpoche.
And we were told that everything is booked
already.
But five minutes later he called us.
Tim Ferriss: Now, just so I'm clear.
So he is which teacher?
Daniil Liberman: Rinpoche is like a Tibetan
—
Tim Ferriss: Spiritual.
Daniil Liberman: — spiritual, yes.
David Liberman: It's like a title which you
can get only from your childhood if you recognize
—
Daniil Liberman: He's recognized as the —
Tim Ferriss: Reincarnation of someone else.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
So this gentleman is in Moscow and Rinpoche
is asking us to come see him.
And we're like, wait, okay, cool.
So we —
David Liberman: Shared our ideas about transparency,
about how in the future we can leave within
governments without physical borders and for
Tibetan peoples it's really important subjects
knowing that they don't have their land.
Daniil Liberman: So it resonated with him.
And when we finished our story by saying,
"And now it's just two of us," he immediately
abrupted us and is like the three of us and
it was touching and unexpected and he finished
his phrase with, "Fly, come visit me in India
in…" what was it?
"...January next year, I am hosting an integration
of a monastery.
Dalai Lama going to be there and I will introduce
you and we'll introduce your ideas together
and we'll see what we can do together."
That meeting actually happened and not happened
at the same time.
So we flew to India, we spent this week in
the monastery in India, Tibetan monastery,
Dalai Lama actually arrived.
We had a non-private meeting with him in a
group of 10 European donors of the monastery.
But then we had to have a one-on-one meeting
with him next morning, which never happened
because the storm came.
I know this is like a movie story.
The storm came and Dalai Lama immediately
took off —
David Liberman: Was packed in to helicopter
—
Daniil Liberman: To the helicopter, the military
helicopter and just disappeared.
And then we're standing there and in half
hour the storm just rushed and flooded the
entire valley —
David Liberman: For the next two days —
Daniil Liberman: For the next two days we
weren't able to leave the place because it
was flooded.
But then a month later we received an email
from a gentleman whose name is Jerry Murdock,
he's the founder of Insight —
David Liberman: Partners, one of the biggest
VC firms in New York.
Daniil Liberman: And the email was like —
David Liberman: "I'm at the dinner…"
Daniil Liberman: "I'm at the dinner with Dalai
Lama and this other monk and they told me
I have to email you and they give me your
email.
So that's what I do."
Tim Ferriss: "That's why I'm emailing."
Daniil Liberman: "That's why I'm emailing
you.
We met this team few months and we become
close friends."
David Liberman: And eventually through the
many different stories, he invited us to a
dinner.
The dinner wasn't really for us.
He thought that other people will come, but
it didn't work.
So he invited us instead and —
Tim Ferriss: Whatever gets the job done.
David Liberman: Yes.
But since this introduction, we always were
quite cautious about everything which —
Daniil Liberman: Was related to him.
I mean Dalai Lama introduced you to someone
—
David Liberman: Could be the reason.
Daniil Liberman: So there should be a reason.
And we always try to help him and be around
and just see where it'll come, where it'll
go.
Tim Ferriss: You're talking about Jerry?
Daniil Liberman: Jerry.
Yes.
And at some point eventually he introduced
us to Evan at his house and then Evan gave
me his phone number just right away at the
meeting.
David Liberman: And it was the right moment
—
Daniil Liberman: Which wasn't expected for
everyone around because that's not what he's
doing.
David Liberman: And we were developing technologies
around 3D avatars —
Daniil Liberman: Computer vision —
David Liberman: — at that moment.
And that's what was exactly what he wanted
—
Tim Ferriss: On his mind.
Daniil Liberman: On his mind was he wanted
to combine a bitmoji, which were the 2D avatars
he acquired from the Canadian company and
3D engine of AR technology of Luxury, the
Ukrainian company he acquired.
He wanted to merge the two technologies, and
our experience in Hollywood was merging technologies.
We literally were transferring the 2D styles
of existing animated shows into 3D and back
and force and back and forth.
David Liberman: In that moment, we're also
focused on 3D avatars and how technology can
actually not a show, not something which require
—
Daniil Liberman: Game type of thinking.
Because we decided right after the financial
transparency for nonprofits didn't work, we
decided that we looked around and realized
that the technology advanced like a computer
vision and style transfers and all this stuff
advanced a lot since we left the CGA graphics
and we realized that we know everything and
more than probably everyone in the field.
So we can try to just start something and
probably going to be going to build a successful
company.
Half a year later, Evan offered us, not offered,
but already acquired us.
Tim Ferriss: And so just for people who might
not have the acronym, so AR, augmented reality.
So people may recognize some of the current
or recent iterations on Snap where you can,
say, put any number of different sort of overlays
of characters.
I mean they do partnerships with all sorts
of companies and so on so that you can add
something to your face that sort of tracks
your eye movement and augments the kind of
visual experience.
So is that what you guys were working on in
some capacity?
David Liberman: This technology, the face-tracking
technology, it was Ukrainian company Luxury,
which they recently acquired before —
Tim Ferriss: Snapchat acquired.
David Liberman: — us.
And we worked how to combine the avatars into
this technology.So right now, 3D version of
bitmojis is the most used avatars daily in
Snapchat.
It's already everyone in your profile and
games in lenses in all places.
Tim Ferriss: And so you guys get acquired
and, if I'm missing a chapter, let me know,
but can you describe what you did, what your
analysis looked like when Snapchat suddenly
started losing users?
I think it was in 2017.
David Liberman: 2018.
Tim Ferriss: 18.
David Liberman: So it was early 2018.
Tim Ferriss: Are you right?
Yes.
David Liberman: 2017, Instagram released their
stories and in the beginning of 2018, new
version, new update version of Snapchat was
the list.
Kim Kardashian tweeted or Kylie Jenner tweets
that no one would use Snapchat anymore.
All the stuff and audience started to decline.
And at that moment most of the people believed
—
Daniil Liberman: Internal idea in the company
was that it's due to the —
David Liberman: Competition.
Tim Ferriss: Public sentiment, competition.
Daniil Liberman: Public sentiment of the bad
new version or competition of —
David Liberman: Instagram.
Daniil Liberman: — Instagram and TikTok
or altogether.
While our analysis of data showed us that
it's not true.
And then the major reason for the decline
of the audience was related to the fact that
Android version of Snapchat after the update
became so slow that people over time developed,
not developed, but gave up.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they just abandoned.
Daniil Liberman: They just abandoned.
Started abandoning.
David Liberman: Yes —
Daniil Liberman: 10 percent of the slowest
devices of Android users could have experienced
up to 40 seconds before the feed with stories
would load.
David Liberman: Next time when you will open
some feed like count to 40.
Tim Ferriss: 40 seconds.
No way.
I'll barely wait for four seconds.
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
So it was so obvious that this was the reason,
but it took some time to —
David Liberman: We realized that we didn't
have any specific position related to that
in the company and we realized that what we
can do is actually to just bring all the insights
which we were able to extract to Evan —
Daniil Liberman: The engineering team to Evan
—
David Liberman: — and to just give him all
the evidences so that more focus can be added
to the problem and to making the app faster.
Tim Ferriss: Now why do you think you guys
spotted this, right?
Because it doesn't sound like it's immediately
your department or responsibilities?
Was the narrative that it was the Jenners
and the Kim Kardashians and then the competition,
was that so accepted at face value that people
weren't looking at the data or what happened?
David Liberman: So there were several reasons
that first of all, it's Android.
Daniil Liberman: Android.
David Liberman: We're Android users and among
executives it was a really rare things to
—
Daniil Liberman: To actually use Android date.
David Liberman: To use Android day to day.
Even he pushed himself to use Android to experience
this all what his users usually experience
when they use Android.
But we use Androids as a day-to-day devices.
We hackers, we don't like limitations of Apple
App stores.
Daniil Liberman: Closed systems.
David Liberman: And closed up ecosystems.
That's why we always were there.
So when we developed our 3D avatars, it was
the first —
Daniil Liberman: It worked, it worked further
faster on Android than on iOS.
David Liberman: Android than iOS, and it was
quite unique to compared to other products.
And through this experience we learned a lot
about some limitations and we already at that
moment looked at some data just for our products
to be launched properly.
Daniil Liberman: We wanted to fix Snapchat's
Android app earlier just for our product to
work better.
David Liberman: And so we had already some
predispositions and beliefs related to that.
Daniil Liberman: Then, when the product was
launched, we decided to research everything
about the user behavior in order to understand
how we can better position our product inside
of the Snapchat ecosystem.
David Liberman: And with such problems.
The challenge, there are different methodologies.
For example, there is a methodology to A/B
tests.
When you launch, half of the users will see
one version and half of users will see —
Tim Ferriss: Different one.
David Liberman: A different version, and then
you will compare the results.
But with performance degradation, the result
is delayed.
It's not immediate.
You cannot really, it's really hard to —
Tim Ferriss: It's not apples to apples.
David Liberman: Yes.
So you need to wait for some time.
You need data for longer period of time —
Daniil Liberman: And more or less you need
to break it, give your users a bad version,
wait for them to use it for a long enough
period for you to see the difference in behavior.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds like a tough assignment.
David Liberman: Yes.
Evan's decision, moral decision, was never
do that.
So you shouldn't really make the experience
of users worse intentionally.
Daniil Liberman: And as hackers, for us it
was like, okay, can we find a way how to get
this data anyway?
So we started to look at all the previous
bugs.
David Liberman: Accidental, accidental.
Tim Ferriss: Mistakes.
David Liberman: Degradations.
Daniil Liberman: Which led to and then was
discovered, but lasted for long enough so
that we can actually extract the change in
behavior data.
David Liberman: Still it's really important
to note in the article in The New Yorker,
the words not from us.
That's why they are not as clear.
There were people inside of Snap who also
believe in this idea, not only us.
Daniil Liberman: It was basically their initiative,
we just —
David Liberman: There were not enough momentum.
Daniil Liberman: And arguments.
David Liberman: Certainly not enough people
who would work on this problem.
They were really brilliant engineers who already
before that started to rewrite that Android
application.
Daniil Liberman: And we had our daily meeting
with Evan, so we actually could have —
Tim Ferriss: You could be good ambassadors.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: So we used our previously
earned —
Tim Ferriss: Like social capital.
David Liberman: Social capital.
Daniil Liberman: Social capital of building
this avatar product.
David Liberman: We need to just spend all
the social capital on this problem, otherwise
its shares dropped to five dollars per share
from 20 in the entire computation of ours.
Tim Ferriss: In the equity, of course.
David Liberman: In equity of course.
And also we saw the opportunity.
For us, we got through two major crises in
our life, not counting the childhood crisis,
financial crisis.
That's why somehow for us, when it is a crisis
for us, it's a great times.
So it’s like —
Daniil Liberman: Now we can show how we can
—
Tim Ferriss: Never let a good crisis go to
waste.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, exactly.
And at some point we just had to show that
we are good engineers as well.
So David, just in order to challenge the status
quo, David had to sit down and fix camera.
I mean camera, Snapchat is camera and David
made it load, what was it?
David Liberman: Twice as fast.
Daniil Liberman: Twice as fast.
David Liberman: Like not load.
When you press the button, how fast the picture
would be ready.
I showed that it can be —
Daniil Liberman: The speed can be doubled,
and it was like, "Oh, wow.
So yes, your guys also are great engineers
as well.
So how did you do that?"
And we showed some of the principles of how
you can find inefficiencies in the code.
David Liberman: But still it's really important
in the sense that it was a really team effort
of great engineers actually was part of this
process.
What we see is our contribution, this kind
of promotion, this idea.
Daniil Liberman: Their voice was heard.
David Liberman: And bringing this voice to
the decision makers so that they also will
be empowered with data to then thread it to
the entire organization.
And that was definitely really great times
and it worked.
And even though Snapchat has some challenges
right now with —
Daniil Liberman: Revenue.
David Liberman: Financial side of things,
but with audience since then it's growing.
Daniil Liberman: The audience is growing.
David Liberman: They recently reached like
800 million.
Daniil Liberman: The audience is growing in
the countries where the Androids are even
slower.
So the app actually is pretty significant
still.
David Liberman: It's still right now in terms
of Android apps, it's still one of the fastest
apps to load compared to the major apps outside.
Daniil Liberman: What was interesting as well,
so launching a new updated version only happened
when in March-ish of 2019.
But it was also important and we put lots
of efforts into this program more than the
other one to fix the existing version.
Before the new was released, the old had to
be fixed in order to stop bleeding.
And by December the bleeding stopped.
David Liberman: You can see it's from data.
Daniil Liberman: And in January the audience
started to grow.
David Liberman: Even before the new version
—
Daniil Liberman: And in March, the new version
was released.
It never actually slowed down since then.
Tim Ferriss: So I have a question about this
type of data-driven analysis.
Do you attempt to do this type of analysis
with goals or challenges that you have in
your personal lives?
Do you try to apply it everywhere?
Are there examples that you could give outside
of the business context?
David Liberman: First of all, we should know
that we, as Daniil mentioned about intuition,
we believe in both.
We believe in intuition, we believe in data
approach.
But yes, so for example, one was a major principle
is that we know what is compound growth.
And for example, when we have some crazy goals,
crazy for some people, we will set some goals
and these goals seems to be impossible.
What we show again and again that actually
if you have KPI, for example, number of followers.
Daniil Liberman: If you have —
David Liberman: Goals, for example, number
of followers or a number of dollars in your
pocket.
Daniil Liberman: Quantify.
David Liberman: Quantifiable things.
Tim Ferriss: Quantifiable key performance.
David Liberman: What you can do is that you
can evaluate what you have right now and then
if you can multiply this number two.
Daniil Liberman: If you can double.
David Liberman: Two times a year actually.
Daniil Liberman: Every year, if you can double
your results.
David Liberman: It is a greatness.
You have the entire money on Earth, the entire
—
Daniil Liberman: Population on Earth.
David Liberman: Population of following, et
cetera.
So it's really important then when you have
this big goals, you can have any big goal
with this approach.
You just —
Daniil Liberman: You need to run faster than
—
David Liberman: Doubling.
Daniil Liberman: Two times every year.
David Liberman: Actually what we realized
that there is this corridor.
Daniil Liberman: There’s probably a physical
limitation at the top, which is around 2.4.
You cannot run faster than increasing your
results 2.4 times a year in a —
David Liberman: Long.
Daniil Liberman: Long run.
David Liberman: But what we realized that
actually it's really tiny corridor.
If you increase this number 1.6 times, you're
successful.
If you increase this number 2.4 times, you
are —
Daniil Liberman: You're superhuman.
David Liberman: Superhuman.
Daniil Liberman: You're like, godlike.
David Liberman: So this is only as a small
corridor, you don't need to think about something
faster.
If it's —
Daniil Liberman: Anything slower, it just
like a normal life.
David Liberman: Slower, it will not be success.
Tim Ferriss: Now this is multiplying your
KPI by 1.7 times every year.
Daniil Liberman: Every year.
David Liberman: Every year.
Tim Ferriss: Every year.
Once per year.
David Liberman: Once per year.
Daniil Liberman: Once per year.
David Liberman: And we applied it a lot in
our life, in our business life, in the life
of our companies, in our personal life.
So we use this methodology.
Tim Ferriss: How do you apply it?
What would be an example from the personal
life?
Maybe it doesn't have to follow that doubling
heuristic.
It could, but what might be an example?
David Liberman: But for example, amount of
hours you spent with as a romantic partner,
you inspired by.
Tim Ferriss: And so you would track the hours
and then look to multiply that over time?
David Liberman: Yes.
So you shouldn't expect that immediately.
You would start a relationship which would
be perfect and you will spend all the time
and all this time would be perfect and great,
et cetera.
But if you have one hour of this experience
a year, the next year it can be two hours
as the next year it can be four hours.
Daniil Liberman: For some it might sound like
—
David Liberman: In 10 years you have the entire
life like that.
Tim Ferriss: Slow build.
David Liberman: Slow build.
And we just realized that when you try to
run faster, you can actually break yourself.
Tim Ferriss: I see what you're saying.
So you can make a mistake by saying, "Okay,
I'm going to spend half of my time this year
with this person," because you're sort of
biting off more than you can chew and maybe
shooting yourself in the foot for the long
term.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So basically having an eye towards growth
but not being excessively ambitious in the
beginning because you'll break things.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
I know on personal experience, yes.
This is like when you run too much right away,
you break stuff.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I can see that as someone
who's suffered a lot of physical breakage
also.
David Liberman: But even with the acceleration,
when you're in the rockets flying into space,
there is this limitation of three —
Daniil Liberman: 3G.
David Liberman: G, three times G, which then
actually start breaking stuff in yourself.
So it seems that it's kind of natural number.
This is what we can sustain like 2.4 like
to 1.6.
This is something which we can sustain physically
and mentally and you can achieve everything.
Daniil Liberman: And you can honestly you
can find it anywhere.
If you want to play music, just start from
something achievable right now today, double
your result every year.
David Liberman: And you will become like Beyoncé.
Daniil Liberman: You will soon become superstar.
Tim Ferriss: Superstars.
Daniil Liberman: Superstar.
Tim Ferriss: Certainly true with physical
activity too.
If you think about say weightlifting or whatever,
you don't need to 10X a number every year.
And if you try —
Daniil Liberman: You want 10X.
You can try.
Tim Ferriss: If you try it like I've tried,
then you start damaging your connective tissue
or needing surgeries.
David Liberman: I remember that was one of
the Olympic teams, was it in UK or something
like that?
I don't remember exactly, but they got a new
tech trainer and the new trainer was —
Daniil Liberman: A coach.
David Liberman: Coach was with this approach,
but the approach was like we need to improve
our KPIs one percent a week.
It's almost the same.
And they become champion from nowhere.
Daniil Liberman: Years later they become champion
from nowhere.
The last position on the list they become
champions.
David Liberman: So but physical activity is
the same and business activity, money, finance.
Daniil Liberman: Writing books, music.
David Liberman: But really important is that
you can achieve anything.
You can have any type of mission or big goals,
but then you draw this course for yourself
—
Tim Ferriss: As long as you're consistent.
David Liberman: And be consistent.
Tim Ferriss: So what are some of the maybe
logistics challenges and how have you addressed
them in running your businesses, how you run
them or organizing your lives, the way that
you guys organize them?
Daniil Liberman: We have a very messed up
calendar.
It's like multidimensional.
Tim Ferriss: Does that mean that you're just
traveling all over the place?
Do you have —
David Liberman: We travel a lot for sure.
Daniil Liberman: We travel a lot.
We probably this year we're in the States
for three months all over the year.
But at home in L.A., even less maybe than
that, maybe one week a month, not more than
that.
David Liberman: But what helped a lot, it
started with two of us, but quite fast, two
of our sisters joined and they usually —
Daniil Liberman: And they don't travel that
much.
David Liberman: And they usually run operations
and scaling of their projects.
Tim Ferriss: Do any of your other siblings
have the pair bonding that you guys have?
David Liberman: No.
It didn't work.
But five of us, we are quite close and we
work together.
Daniil Liberman: We work together, we live
together in L.A. Our houses is literally like
two minutes away from each other.
David Liberman: Yes, and they start to run
operations scenes, game development.
And then they come —
Daniil Liberman: Became our equal partners.
David Liberman: The equal partners in animation
studio.
And in since then it's much easier for us
to dream more and to act.
Daniil Liberman: No, now we discuss everything
together.
Philosophy, the vision for the future, the
morality.
It's a constant discussion among all of us.
Tim Ferriss: So I can imagine, I'm just putting
myself in the place of people listening to
this that I'm sure there are people out there
who work with family and then there are other
people who don't work with family.
But I imagine working with my family and I
love my family, but I'm like, "Wow, if I hired
two people from my family to run my operations,"
what do you do if it's not working?
Would you ever fire them or do you just have
complete confidence that you can resolve anything
that might come up?
How do you think about —
David Liberman: You definitely can fire, but
for sure.
Daniil Liberman: I mean what we learned —
David Liberman: What we learned.
So we went through really harsh experience
with game development to the bankruptcy and
they were the only ones who stayed with us.
Daniil Liberman: Stayed with us.
David Liberman: Through it was a challenging
period.
And when you actually went through such experience,
it's much easier to trust.
Not trust just because it's family, but because
you know what you can expect.
Tim Ferriss: You saw how they behaved.
David Liberman: Especially in venture business
when as we mentioned most of the attempts.
Daniil Liberman: Would fail.
David Liberman: Would fail.
It is really important quality to have someone
who you can trust that they are with you long
term, not just for this project.
And I would say this worked pretty well.
Maybe this was the results of this experience,
which we all had, but maybe just because our
parents worked together.
For us, we didn't have this concept [inaudible]
that it's not right.
Tim Ferriss: You saw that modeled.
Daniil Liberman: Never work with your family?
No!
David Liberman: And we went through challenges.
Definitely we argue with each other, et cetera.
So we went through a lot of challenges but
it worth it.
Tim Ferriss: Well, I was thinking also, as
you saw your sisters, I suppose, doing the
challenges of the game development company
has reminded me of a quote, I don't know the
attribution, but that's in English is a common
expression.
"Adversity builds character."
But the alternative, which I think might be
just as true or maybe truer, is "Adversity
doesn't build character.
It reveals character."
Daniil Liberman: Reveals character.
Tim Ferriss: And so you got to see how they
responded to a lot of challenge, which gave
you the confidence then.
David Liberman: And there were a lot of challenges.
Daniil Liberman: We are lucky in many ways.
Tim Ferriss: So I want to ask you about, so
this is the same question applied to two different
groups.
So the first is going to be your parents and
I wanted just ask about what ideas of theirs
you find most interesting.
Maybe that's a place to talk about [inaudible],
maybe not.
But then the second is what ideas you guys
are most excited about right now.
But I wanted to start with —
Daniil Liberman: Do we have a couple more
hours for each?
David Liberman: Yeah, exactly.
So our parents, so our dad, he was from physics,
but he was by government, pushed out from
physics because he was Jew and —
Daniil Liberman: And switched to biology.
David Liberman: Biology because biophysics
was an open field.
Tim Ferriss: Physics was more protected and
Jews were more discriminated against in physics?
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: So he found this niche, it
was a new niche, it was an emerging new science.
He came there with knowledge of physics and
that gave him a different perspective than
most —
Daniil Liberman: An advantage.
David Liberman: Biologists.
Tim Ferriss: A huge advantage.
David Liberman: Who would see everything through
prism of chemistry or through a prism of biology.
Daniil Liberman: He looked at it through the
prism of physics.
David Liberman: And he started discovering
things —
Daniil Liberman: Faster.
David Liberman: Faster in this field —
Daniil Liberman: Starting with the first thing
which he discovered was that the color which
received by an eye is encoded not in the frequency,
which is then translated as a signal inside
of the eye nerve, but as a pattern of signal
—
David Liberman: Pauses in between spikes.
Daniil Liberman: Pauses in between spikes.
David Liberman: So this pattern is encoded.
Daniil Liberman: It's almost like Morse, de-de-de-de.
Tim Ferriss: Morse code.
Daniil Liberman: And this is sort of like
—
David Liberman: That's how he realized that
it should be a computer is there, that should
be a computation because the encoding happened.
Daniil Liberman: He came to this idea, there
was a really interesting weird obsession of
his on the idea that if evolution was working
properly for millions of years, if not billions
of years, then it should be optimal.
That the most optimal mechanisms should have
survived the evolution process and therefore
what's the most optimal from the physics perspective
in terms of measuring —
David Liberman: Amount of energy spent on
the operation.
Daniil Liberman: On operation and data is
like time in between the quantum events.
This is probably the most optimal one.
And from this perspective, from the perspective
—
David Liberman: He was able to find —
Daniil Liberman: Optimality, he was trying
to find how the eye works and he was the one
to discover exactly how it works.
And he's like, "Wow.
So I was right about optimality," and then
used optimality all the way down, exploring
into the nerve, into the neuron and into the
core of the cell, into the DNA and then across
the entire cell.
David Liberman: So Chematic was the abbreviation
of chemistry, chemistry.
Daniil Liberman: Chemistry.
David Liberman: Optics and mathematics.
So he always believes that the real discoveries
are in combination of different fields, that
actually the fact that we learn this subject
separately —
Daniil Liberman: Limiting us.
David Liberman: Limiting us in terms of us
being able to discover some things, which
requires you to look at some —
Tim Ferriss: Have some interdisciplinary synthesis.
Daniil Liberman: He was pushing this idea
of interdisciplinary synthesis.
David Liberman: And their success, both of
our dad and mom, their success was because
of that.
They would combine things which others wouldn't
combine.
For example, he brought the quantum physics
—
Daniil Liberman: Into cells.
David Liberman: Describing cells processes.
So even he, maybe 2008, 2010, it was really
emerging idea in science.
Scientists, they were trying to avoid —
Daniil Liberman: Avoid as much as —
David Liberman: As much as possible some complicated
processes in biology because —
Daniil Liberman: Not just in chemistry.
David Liberman: It will challenge the idea
that it happened randomly and that they was
trying to avoid that.
I can only recently more and more discoveries
around photosynthesis, which probably requires
quantum tunneling.
And then there's the smell and the fact that
the birds can see the direction of —
Daniil Liberman: Polarization of light.
David Liberman: Polarization of light and
where is North Pole.
This all can be described only through the
quantum properties of some processes.
Daniil Liberman: Processes.
David Liberman: Which happened inside —
Daniil Liberman: In life.
David Liberman: So biggest discovery, which
we personally, it's the last discovery.
It's always like that.
Daniil Liberman: It’s not just discovery.
It's like the entire concept that our consciousness
work through the quantum compute inside every
single neuron.
So every single neuron is sort of a qubit.
It's like a quantum state machine itself,
which then combined in the network produce
all the results.
But every neuron is quantum state machine.
David Liberman: This can actually explain
a lot about our psychology, about how we think,
how our consciousness work, but also it can
give humanity a lot of clues, how to build
proper quantum computers.
So currently the quantum computers, which
we build like Google builds or Microsoft builds,
they are all requires some really complicated
environments.
So you need to froze the computers to minus
270 degrees.
Daniil Liberman: Fully isolated from any chaotic
fields.
David Liberman: Electromagnetic fields and
stuff.
So it's really complicated.
While if our parents write in every cell —
Daniil Liberman: Every cell in our body has
a quantum —
David Liberman: This what's happening in a
room temperature.
So we can actually look at how biology made
it and then build a new class of quantum computers
which can actually [inaudible].
And then this can accelerate the personal
AI development, not the corporation's big
AI, but the one which would be with you always
and things like that.
Daniil Liberman: Plus there is a chance also
as well that if this processes are happening
inside of the cell, the answer to a room temperature
—
David Liberman: Superconductors, also.
Daniil Liberman: Superconductors can also
be there somewhere.
I know that recently there was this entire
hype with supposedly discovery of the —
David Liberman: Room temperature superconductors.
Daniil Liberman: The room temperature superconductors.
David Liberman: It seems that it didn't work
this time fully, but why everyone was so excited
because it can change everything.
It can change how we build roads, it can change
how we build —
Daniil Liberman: Understanding —
David Liberman: Electrical grids and things
like that.
Daniil Liberman: Understanding the quantum
limitation.
All roads can be done from superconductors.
If all roads can build, then we have flying
cars.
If the same roads can then become the electric
network which distributes electricity around
the globe from sustainable sources of energy,
like solar panels.
We have days somewhere each hour all the time.
And if the superconductors can surround the
planet, then we have electricity everywhere
without the losing of power.
Lots of stuff can come from the superconductors.
The answer can be inside of ourselves.
David Liberman: Yeah.
So and the biggest discovery was that the
answer can be inside of the cells.
If we can actually look at the properties
of these nanotubes and they are really special.
This really right now there are a lot of discoveries
showing that these nanotubes have properties
which no one would expect that they would
have.
Even though we all know about physics and
chemistry, but we cannot predict these properties.
Daniil Liberman: We're not quite sure about,
because this is recent, probably not even
published or maybe some discussions in the
conferences is happening that the nanotubes
of that sort, the cytoskeleton nanotubes,
how is it called?
Microtubules, they can capture photons, they
can capture light and direct it within its
structure as the light actually hits the microtubules,
the photon goes inside the tube and then as
if it's a core, which captures a light.
And then —
David Liberman: So a lot of freely unexpected
and great properties which can be used in
industries and which can be used by humanity
to just accelerate our development.
So this we believe that —
Daniil Liberman: This is one the most exciting
part about our parents.
David Liberman: What is important is that
they just realize that to achieve that we
need to be interdisciplinary and we need to
combine through the last years, he was a promoters
that he believes that in schools we should
teach kids like that.
Not to teach physics and chemistry and biology,
but —
Daniil Liberman: Not separately.
David Liberman: But teach it —
Daniil Liberman: Altogether.
David Liberman: Altogether and show how all
this interconnected and that we need to kind
of grow a new generation of scientists who
wouldn't be so —
Tim Ferriss: Siloed.
David Liberman: Siloed in the disciplines.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So I want to segue to the ideas that you guys
are currently most excited about.
Thank you for explaining all that.
Every time, anyway, I could spend hours just
digging into what you just said.
Maybe another time.
But since you mentioned teaching, which relates
to learning, how would you teach kids to code
or people to code?
Daniil Liberman: Oh, that's interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Versus how it's maybe currently
taught.
David Liberman: So first of all, we saw that
computer science historically emerged from
mathematics —
Daniil Liberman: And geeky minds like ours.
David Liberman: So it's really great for us.
But for most people it's really alienating
because see, if you're not good in math, you
—
Daniil Liberman: Mathematics.
David Liberman: Mathematics, you will just
avoid even —
Daniil Liberman: Trying.
David Liberman: Because you will think that
you are not really great in that.
In reality —
Daniil Liberman: It's a language.
David Liberman: Coding is much closer to learning
French or learning Japanese.
It's actually much —
Daniil Liberman: Easier.
Tim Ferriss: A friend of mine published a
small book, which was basically Code Is Poetry.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: Oh, that's interesting.
Can you share it?
Because we actually also wrote a tiny book,
like Code Is a Language?
Tim Ferriss: Sure, I'll find it for you.
I'll find it for you.
And I'm not sure if he published it, but he
gave it away as a gift.
Matt Mullenweg, who's the founder and CEO
of Automattic and was one of the lead developers,
arguably the lead developer of WordPress.
Daniil Liberman: Probably need to combine
our thoughts in one book and then publish
it.
Tim Ferriss: I'll find it for you.
David Liberman: I created during pandemic,
had some additional time.
So I created interactive —
Daniil Liberman: Online course.
David Liberman: Book where you learned that
you can actually first type something in a
normal language, descriptions of world.
Daniil Liberman: Description of the [inaudible].
David Liberman: And then it can be easily
translated by you into —
Daniil Liberman: Coding.
David Liberman: Coding language and like Python
or C++ or Swift.
Daniil Liberman: It's actually like a translation.
First you wrote it in your own language and
then you translate it into the code.
David Liberman: So the only thing which you
need to learn is a little bit different —
Daniil Liberman: Grammar rules.
David Liberman: Little different way to describe
the world.
And that's what mostly you should learn.
You shouldn't learn the words.
Daniil Liberman: Punctuation.
David Liberman: Punctuation and [inaudible]
of this language.
And if you use these methods to learn, then
you can actually code —
Daniil Liberman: In any language.
David Liberman: In any language because it
appears that Swift or C++, they all the same.
They all interchangeable.
Every time when I interview an engineer and
this engineer would say that, "I know only
this language," this will be a red flag for
me because it means that you don't really
understand and all this languages, they're
almost the same.
Yes.
So there are nuances, but you almost don't
have tasks which actually require you to use
this nuances.
But if you understand the kind of meta language
and this meta language is really close to
—
Tim Ferriss: Natural language.
David Liberman: Natural language, then you
can actually code into any language.
That's what we really promote and we happen
to actually teach some people coding who would
never think that they can code and who would
think that mathematics is not theirs.
Daniil Liberman: Moms of two.
David Liberman: Moms, yes.
Daniil Liberman: Housewives.
They are great.
Because they're great in language, and if
you're great in language, you can actually
learn this language as well.
Especially right now, even though, yes, ChatGPT's
of the world, they can code for yourself,
but if you know how to code, you will be well
off in the next 20 years, 10-20 years.
Tim Ferriss: So for people who are listening,
if they are resonating with what you're saying
— for instance, I'm a casualty of mathematics.
I was actually very good at math.
My brother, also very good at math, and we
had very different experiences with teachers.
He had a few great teachers, and I had one
very, very angry, abusive teacher, and so
I said, "No more math for me" even though
I was innately quite good at it.
He kept going and got PhD in statistics, and
he's very math capable.
But I developed an adolescent onset allergy.
But I recognize the beauty and elegance and
value of code.
I don't think I would ever use it as a profession,
but I like the idea of testing myself but
I've always struggled with trying to identify
how to start.
I've looked at AI as maybe a way to use an
intermediary, so I can use natural language
to do some type of coding, but how would you
suggest to someone who is interested, maybe
a little nervous, but would like to explore
coding?
David Liberman: There is a free book on our
Instagram.
There is link which you can try.
It's definitely only the first step.
Then, you will need to learn more, but at
least through the step, our expectation is
that you will stop being nervous and afraid
of coding, and it would be more natural for
you.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
That's step one.
Daniil Liberman: That's step one.
David Liberman: That's why we wrote this book,
just to make it easy because I don't like
any other courses, because they all start
with syntaxes, et cetera.
It is not the way you start.
Daniil Liberman: It's not the way you start.
They are great courses, it's just not the
way you start, because you alienate people
who are like, "Oh, function.
What is function?"
They're unable —
Tim Ferriss: I don't know anything about coding,
but it's the same with foreign languages,
right?
You see the way that they're taught, and it's
like, "Okay, here's a huge table of conjugations,
memorize this," and people are like, "No thanks,
I'm out."
Daniil Liberman: Yeah, no thanks.
David Liberman: I'm out.
Exactly.
Tim Ferriss: No, here's a comic book.
Let's look at some things that you can use
immediately, make it fun, and then later we
can do the harder stuff.
David Liberman: Also what we found, that's
how we learn how to code, is that —
Daniil Liberman: Other examples.
David Liberman: Usually when you learn language,
you first read, not write, you read.
You need to read some easy but good written
—
Tim Ferriss: Book.
David Liberman: — book, to learn the language.
Daniil Liberman: With software engineers,
it's the same.
We actually —
David Liberman: We mocked an Instagram application,
and we wrote a simple Instagram application.
Daniil Liberman: We re-wrote a clean code
of a simple Instagram application.
David Liberman: Because everyone knows what
it is, and everyone understand how it works,
so if you read this code, you understand what
it will do —
Daniil Liberman: In the middle of the course
you're just, "Okay, now change."
Now change some stuff in the code and you
will see the changes in the app.
And as you change the parts of the code, you
see the changes in the app and you're like,
"Oh, that's how it works."
Tim Ferriss: Also positive feedback.
David Liberman: Absolutely.
Also, even if you decide not to be an engineer,
even for example, if you are a product person,
product manager or marketing person.
Daniil Liberman: QA.
David Liberman: It's really important for
you to understand, otherwise, you won't be
able to give properly the tasks to engineers.
You won't be able to manage engineers and
losing a lot of opportunities.
You will always be triggered by engineers
because you will ask them to do something,
but they will do something really different
if you don't really understand their language.
But as soon as you do, it actually helps you
out.
Daniil Liberman: I wish we had more time and
more eager to actually finish the full course,
but it's absolutely not the primary goal in
our hectic life as well.
Tim Ferriss: But I'll link to that in the
show notes so that people who are interested
can at least find it and give it a shot.
I might do the same thing.
Ideas, exciting ideas.
Daniil Liberman: Exciting ideas.
Tim Ferriss: Things that are, it could be
projects, could be missions, could be ideas.
Just things that have you both feeling excited
and motivated.
Daniil Liberman: Where do we go?
Identity international gap.
David Liberman: So I sense ideas —
Daniil Liberman: AI.
David Liberman: — through two things.
First, observations which we have about the
world.
And this observation, they give us a different
perspective and this perspective is almost
obviously led us to some ideas.
Daniil Liberman: And projects.
David Liberman: And then usually when we have
ideas, these ideas exist in us for some years
and then we try to crystallize them into projects.
Daniil Liberman: Into product.
David Liberman: One of the major observations
which actually started from bankruptcy of
game development studio, we really wanted
to understand "What was that?"
Daniil Liberman: What the hell happened?
David Liberman: Financial crisis.
Daniil Liberman: Financial crisis.
David Liberman: How we missed it.
Daniil Liberman: Not that we missed it.
We saw that there was a problem in the real
estate market, but everything collapsed around
real estate market.
David Liberman: We thought that just real
estate market will collapse, but everything
collapsed.
Daniil Liberman: Little did we know about
how the financial market works.
David Liberman: Yes.
So then we dig deeper and first we got to
the same —
Daniil Liberman: Conclusion.
David Liberman: — conclusions than everyone,
like economists.
Daniil Liberman: Derivatives, credit default
swaps.
David Liberman: Deregulation to 2001.
Daniil Liberman: This all lasts to this bubble.
David Liberman: But for us, usually people
—
Daniil Liberman: Sometimes like all this stuff.
David Liberman: Yes, people usually when it's
about derivative in credit default swaps,
blame the bankers.
Daniil Liberman: Everyone blames bankers.
David Liberman: Oh, bankers, they made this
deregulation, they had the problem.
And that's how it all happens.
But every time when we have a statement, we
check it with data and we decide to [inaudible]
who was the actual beneficiary.
Beneficiary of credit default swaps.
Daniil Liberman: Not of their fault, but of
them being created and popularized that way.
David Liberman: And then we realized that
most of the credit default swaps through some
vehicles, they were owned by pension funds.
We're like, what?
Because we are from a region where pension
funds, really small pensioners are really
poor people and you would never think that
they all sell multi-trillion dollar —
Tim Ferriss: Huge.
Huge.
Daniil Liberman: The United States are like,
what is it?
David Liberman: 40 trillion dollars in assets.
It's more than the entire publicly traded
market combined.
You will combine all Apple, Google, Exxon,
Walmart, you will combine all these companies.
It's smaller than the assets of pension funds.
Daniil Liberman: Altogether less than the
assets of pension funds.
David Liberman: So through this reason, we
started to learn more and more like how the
hell it happened —
Daniil Liberman: And it was green invention.
I mean the fact that United States is the
greatest economy in the world is because of
this.
David Liberman: So we realize it's not because
of the army, not military.
Daniil Liberman: It's because of people actually
were saving some big chunk of their money,
and the money was not just saved but was invested
into the market and that's how market got
all the capital to grow, et cetera, et cetera,
et cetera.
David Liberman: But then realized that unfortunately
as soon as this population not only grew to
the amounts that are the majority of voters,
but also they have this enormous financial
power, the financial power, which bigger than
the banks, the bigger than any other organization.
So this financial power in this voting power
—
Daniil Liberman: Together combined led to
lots of popular political decisions.
David Liberman: And regulations.
Daniil Liberman: And regulations which was
completely false.
David Liberman: Which led to —
Daniil Liberman: What types of things?
We can give you some taste of it.
Yeah.
David Liberman: For example, when we first
came to United States, we learned about student
debt.
Daniil Liberman: Student loan.
David Liberman: And for you it's obvious it's
United States, everything is commercial.
That's why college is not free.
That's how we got to the student debt.
But the student debt, if you will look at
the size, before 2000, it was really a small
problem.
It's now like $2 trillion.
But before that it was a much, much, much,
much smaller problems.
And what we realized that previously in the
'80s, your tuition when you go to state college
would be mostly subsidized by government.
90 percent of your tuition would be subsidized
by government.
That's how your parents were able to actually
pay for their tuition during the summer job,
there's a summer job.
And that's how the debts never accumulated
as much.
But in the late '80s, beginning of '90s, because
of almost bankruptcy, state of —
Daniil Liberman: Public pension funds.
David Liberman: Public pension funds.
Daniil Liberman: In many states.
David Liberman: The governments in different
states and in federal level as well.
Daniil Liberman: Bailed out.
David Liberman: Made a decision to not only
bail out, but also for the future, protect
these pension funds.
For example, in California, the growth of
public pension funds, including teachers funds
guaranteed on the level of 7.8 percent a year.
Imagine that your deficit would be guaranteed
as this level.
Daniil Liberman: A state budget.
David Liberman: And it's not even average.
Tim Ferriss: State budget.
So the subsidies to education went down as
a result.
David Liberman: Yes, exactly.
So it's —
Daniil Liberman: You can see because during
[inaudible] —
David Liberman: The money is still there.
Daniil Liberman: Tons of information become
publicly available online.
David Liberman: You can trace it.
Daniil Liberman: You can trace it.
It's all there.
David Liberman: So this is from —
Daniil Liberman: Tons of data, but if you
like to dig this data, you can find it.
It's just there.
You can see it.
You can like, "Oh, right, the money goes into
the education."
Then —
Tim Ferriss: There's a pension fund.
David Liberman: There's a pension fund like
CalPERS in California.
Tim Ferriss: In California.
David Liberman: Yes.
It's public pension funds pension fund, the
public workers pension fund of teachers of
California.
No one really realized the size of these funds.
Daniil Liberman: And no one really realized
the gap in between —
David Liberman: Assets and liabilities of
this fund.
Daniil Liberman: Assets and liabilities of
So when everyone discusses that pension funds
are underfunded —
David Liberman: It's only public pension funds.
Daniil Liberman: It's only public pensions
funds which are underfunded.
David Liberman: It's $5 trillion of a gap,
$5 trillion.
And this is accounting the money which is
constantly transferred.
Daniil Liberman: Someone might think that
—
David Liberman: From subsidies to the pension
funds instead of subsidies.
Daniil Liberman: Someone might think that
this is just public workers.
They're probably what?
15 percent of workforce in United States.
And yet the size of their pension funds is
half of all pension funds.
David Liberman: Even though it's only 15 percent
of workforce.
Daniil Liberman: Why?
Because of a guaranteed 7.8 percent analog
growth.
Because when the rest of the market goes down,
up, down, up.
David Liberman: And this problem is not only
indication.
If you look at the police, there was this
big movement of underfunding police.
And we looked at the budget and per person
in L.A. for example, per officer in L.A.,
it's almost like 250,000 a year.
Daniil Liberman: And people were very angry
about that.
"What the hell, we pay you a lot and you're
not doing your job."
But then what —
David Liberman: The real work is right now,
and the real officers right now —
Daniil Liberman: Are not paid as much.
David Liberman: — are not paid as much.
And they get only a tiny portion of it and
most of it goes as a transfer for pension
funds for officers who worked 30 years ago.
Daniil Liberman: Now again —
Tim Ferriss: So where does this lead?
You guys are looking at the data and I suppose
a good set of data ideally allows you to have
some predictive ability or at least speculation
ability.
So what do you do with this after identifying.
David Liberman: So we realized that every
next generation because of that —
Daniil Liberman: Zooming out to a larger picture,
what it led to is that through the generations
starting saying from Boomers, I know this
is like a false signs about dividing people
into these generations, but we can batch —
David Liberman: People who was born around
the '50s, yes, let's say.
Daniil Liberman: The Boomers, as they were
getting into 30 years old, on average as a
generation, own something around 21 —
David Liberman: 23 percent.
Daniil Liberman: 23 percent of national wealth
in the United States.
The following generation Gen Xes at the same
age, average age owned around seven.
Us, the Millennials, by the same age, owned
only less than three percent, like 2.8-ish.
And then the trajectory shows us that together
with the crisis which happened during the
COVID, we can expect that the next generation
after are the Gen Z are going to be in debt.
David Liberman: By the same average —
Daniil Liberman: By the average age.
So they still —
David Liberman: So its trajectory —
Daniil Liberman: — on average as a generation,
they're still going to be in debt.
David Liberman: So trajectory really bad.
Tim Ferriss: Sounds bad.
David Liberman: And also what this created
that if these young people, not if, when they
realize that the social agreement is not working,
social structures will start to fall apart.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think are some likely
ways that that will show up?
Daniil Liberman: We'll see the new wave of
unions, protests, people not working, economies
slowing down.
This stuff, new businesses not created.
We can see from the statistics that over the
last 10 years, the share of the new businesses
created in the United States.
And in the United States, lots of new businesses
created every year.
Lots of them never survive the year.
But that's the case.
You create many, many, many businesses and
lots of them die and some of them survive.
And that's the economy.
So the share of the new businesses created
annually in the United States, by the people
under 30 years old used to be 40 percent or
45, let's say 40.
And now 10 years later, now it's a 30, so
it's down 10 percent.
Tim Ferriss: Is the same number of companies
being built just by younger and older?
Or is the total number —
Daniil Liberman: It's just more people, more
companies.
The total number is sort of the same.
It's just not young people creating them,
it's people 55 plus creating them.
Tim Ferriss: That's surprising.
Daniil Liberman: That's surprising.
And not what I would expect.
I never checked the data, but my intuition
tells me all those businesses are just real
estate.
People buying houses and renting them out.
So nothing new is created.
Just the spike in the price in real estate
is just because they're buying and renting
out and those are the new businesses.
David Liberman: So there are a lot of problems.
But still when you talk about the problems,
it's really important also, at least to propose
some solutions.
What we saw, because we realized that this
shift is based on regulations, it's not natural
that this shift is happening.
So regulations which were —
Tim Ferriss: Based on regulations?
David Liberman: Regulations, that's the rules
which was set by the previous generations,
which making this constant transfer.
We realized that if you would decipher the
regulations, what they did, that they made
a preference to equity, to shares of the companies,
et cetera, compared to the income.
Daniil Liberman: Individual income.
David Liberman: So capital gain is taxed less.
There are a lot of things which actually made
the huge difference between equity, how equity
treated by the regulation and by the market
and how personally.
Tim Ferriss: Got it, right.
The taxation —
David Liberman: Everything.
Tim Ferriss: — incentives.
"The expansion funds can invest in that, but
cannot invest in that," and things like that.
So there are limitations set, not naturally.
Daniil Liberman: The majority of the capital
is pension capital.
Then where it can be invested matters a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Sure.
David Liberman: So in this term we realize
that the solution which we can test and propose
—
Daniil Liberman: At least try.
David Liberman: — is to try to convert income
—
Daniil Liberman: Individual Income.
David Liberman: — into securities.
Securities.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
So this is where the Libermans Company comes.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, the Libermans Company
comes.
David Liberman: Yes.
First time we did this to ourselves.
As a scientist, you need to make the experiments
and the experiments first have to —
Tim Ferriss: I wish more scientists did this.
Yeah, you've got to be the first monkey shot
into space.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: At less than three Gs?
Just to be clear.
David Liberman: So we realize, yeah, okay
—
Daniil Liberman: If you want to survive this.
David Liberman: So even though our income
is not stable, but if you will build a model
around all the founders, all tech founders,
and the probabilities of successes during
the period of time, we can build an income
model like you would do with a company, kind
of cashflow projections.
Daniil Liberman: Risk, weighted risk adjusted
cashflow, projection of an entrepreneur.
David Liberman: And then based on these —
Tim Ferriss: Like a value stock.
David Liberman: — projections.
Like yes, but based on these projections you
can actually set a price for a company which
would have the same type of income.
In this case, if you can form the company,
then you can attract investment the same way
companies do.
And in this case he will eliminate this bias
and vice versa will be supercharged by this
—
Daniil Liberman: The capital floating into
personal income.
David Liberman: — improving your future.
Like personal income —
Tim Ferriss: So supercharged, just to try
to ensure I'm hearing you correctly.
So supercharged, meaning if you're showing
a decent rate of growth, even though you're
capital constrained, if you can bring in equity
investors who invest in you as if you were
a company, you can accelerate your growth
and potential.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
And then we can average as an index across
some cohorts of specific professions or specific
cohorts like students for example.
You have higher education or you don't have
higher education.
How does it change your average income?
David Liberman: Should we invest in you having
good education?
Daniil Liberman: Should we invest in every
kid to have the good high education, higher
education for them to increase their individual
income?
And that's where investors get their money
back.
Or should we just leave it to the way it is
right now, with the loan, which then suppresses
the wheel to go and risk?
And that's how young people don't create new
businesses and just go find a shitty job.
Tim Ferriss: So how do you think you incentivize
this type of wider adoption and data sharing,
right?
Because I can imagine if let's just say we
flash forward and this has been widely adopted.
Now I can choose right, do I want to invest
in people who are going getting accounting
degrees where maybe I have a more reliable
return on my investment year-on-year, or do
I want to invest in the growth stocks that
have much higher volatility.
Like the entrepreneurs of a certain class
or maybe age bracket where it's going to be
a much riskier, by volatility measurements,
investment, but who knows the gains could
be higher.
How do you go from a single proof of concept?
I have also questions about taxation.
Just if you're being taxed at an ordinary
income level, how you translate that effectively
to equity holders who might be your investors,
let's just say.
But well, we could tackle any one of those.
So it could be like how do you contend with
maybe the handicap of having ordinary income
taxed, even though that's presumably what
people are investing in on some level, like
the discounted cashflow or whatever.
And then how do you take this and encourage
other people to experiment with it?
David Liberman: Some regulations need to be
changed to make it widely adopted.
Daniil Liberman: But now we start with ourself
as tech entrepreneurs, because most of our
income comes from building companies and selling
companies or the making companies [inaudible].
David Liberman: Even today there is no difference
whether you registered this company under
your name or you registered this company under
a holding company name.
So there is no difference.
Tim Ferriss: That's a great point.
That's a great point.
You guys are actually operating in an easier
case, straightforward case, because most of
your gains would be from companies therefore
likely long-term capital gains.
Maybe you have USBS exclusions, et cetera.
Versus if you guys were highly paid lawyers
or something, it could get a lot trickier.
David Liberman: Yes, we went through that,
prove it to regulators, pave the way through,
show that it works pretty good.
Daniil Liberman: Thousands of entrepreneurs
can actually show in their example that it
works for the investors and then if it works
for the investors, then we can introduce new
regulations which will make it work for the
professionals.
Let's say software engineers, doctors, lawyers.
And from there go to even wider groups like
students.
There need to be even more regulations because
kids need to be protected and stuff like this,
but it all possible to be done.
David Liberman: So we're pretty sure that
at least some politicians who will see is
that their voters can benefit out of it and
that they can actually live better life.
And the problems like student debts can be
solved in just really short term by the tools
like that.
We hope that some rules will change.
Daniil Liberman: And what's interesting right
now, most of the pension funds are invested
in really bubbled overpriced assets just because
it's too much money and not that much of instruments,
like financial instruments, to actually generate
the growth.
David Liberman: That's why they needed this
accredit for swaps and et cetera because they
need this derivatives because it was just
too much money to invest.
So if it would be invested in people —
Daniil Liberman: If we are talking about investing
in people.
David Liberman: — everyone will win.
Pension funds will win, people will win.
It's just the gross economy would be much
faster than it is today.
Daniil Liberman: It's likely going to be 10
times larger market to invest in when we start
investing in individual income as equity.
Tim Ferriss: So what do you say to people
who think about this and they're like, "Okay,
I'm sure there are cases where this would
be very attractive, at least initially."
So you might have somebody like a very promising
YouTuber, they want to build out a studio
and hire.
I guess they could go out and raise an equity
round if they're really —
Daniil Liberman: That's what we did, but with
individual income like in the YouTubers.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Now do you think if somebody is really successful
that they would try to renegotiate or that
they would not try to renegotiate?
David Liberman: There is an example.
It's not us, it was before us.
There is a fund which invested in college
athletes and they proposed to every college
athlete.
They took the statistics because it's quite
statistical thing.
Daniil Liberman: It's like a Moneyball type
of a game.
They calculated their way to understanding
how to predict —
David Liberman: And they offered.
Daniil Liberman: — how many students they
should invest in order to basically hit the
—
Tim Ferriss: Have a couple of LeBron Jameses.
David Liberman: Exactly, yes.
And they offered every student era the same
price, 5-10 percent investment.
Daniil Liberman: We're buying 5-10 percent
of your future income and we pay you the same
price.
It's $10 million.
David Liberman: So half a million, million
for 5-10 percent.
70 students agreed.
Daniil Liberman: Athletes.
David Liberman: One of them already netted
15 years contract for $350 million.
So they did great with the fund.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, they did pretty well.
David Liberman: There is one athlete —
Daniil Liberman: To sue them.
David Liberman: — who tried to challenge
this agreement in court.
Tim Ferriss: This one athlete challenged them?
David Liberman: One athlete.
Tim Ferriss: Was it the same athlete?
David Liberman: No.
This one, there is a great interview of him
where he explains that this man actually helped
him a lot.
Daniil Liberman: Best decision in his life.
David Liberman: He would never do another
decision.
Tim Ferriss: I'm just imagining he might be
cool with it, but I'm thinking about the managers
and the agents who are like, "What the fuck
is this?"
But it worked out.
David Liberman: Yes, it worked out for everyone.
But there is another athlete who netted like
three, $4-million-a-year type of contract.
He tried to challenge this in the court and
everything in this case is more complicated
than with our case.
He was 16 when he signed, English wasn't his
main language, anything like that.
So he signed in, steel court was on the side
of investors, upheld the ingredient.
Tim Ferriss: How can people find more about
this particular example if they wanted to
Google something?
David Liberman: I will send you a link.
Tim Ferriss: You can send it to me, we'll
put it in the show notes.
David Liberman: Yes.
I think it was in Wall Street Journal, the
description of all this case.
But also I can send you the links to the court
case because we Googled it.
All the court cases they opened.
So you can see all the arguments and arguments
of the court.
They were about the fact that he did well.
So it's not about investors taking the glass
screen view, I think like that.
So he did well and also investors described
all the scenarios.
There is a scenario in the agreement that
there is scenario that they will do well and
in this case we'll get this amount of money.
So they described all the scenarios.
Daniil Liberman: Precisely described.
David Liberman: Moreover —
Daniil Liberman: So definitely.
David Liberman: — I don't remember what
was in their contract, but in our contract,
when we —
Tim Ferriss: With your investors?
Daniil Liberman: With our investors, and when
we invest in others —
David Liberman: We also invest, we're not
the founders.
Daniil Liberman: We also invested already
in around a dozen people.
We have this —
David Liberman: Minimal sum, which we don't
touch a year.
Daniil Liberman: — minimal sum which we
don't — minimal income of yours before which
we're not getting anything.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
There's a hurdle, right?
Daniil Liberman: There's a hurdle.
David Liberman: It's not about the last opinion.
Daniil Liberman: It's not about your last
opinions, we actually aim to have the outliers.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, it's a power law distribution.
Daniil Liberman: It's a power law.
David Liberman: In most of industries there
is this power law.
It's not only in tech, it's just in art, in
podcasts, in athletes.
Daniil Liberman: How I feel about this, we
will all win.
The market will win, society will win.
Humanity will win from the fact that we will
use this power law for wider groups of people
to invest in them, provide them capital, and
provide them a chance to get a higher education
to try to start a business.
Tim Ferriss: So question about your investments,
and we can look at it at least two different
ways.
So one could be your investors and why they
chose to invest in you guys?
But since you guys made the decisions about
your investments, I'm curious about those
people.
To what extent did you choose them based on
their earning potential and so on, versus
their potential to be a good ambassador or
story for this model?
Because they both seem to matter, right?
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Now we care about both.
Tim Ferriss: So a good investment may have
the financial ROI, but there's also showcasing.
Daniil Liberman: Obviously, because we have
not that much money to invest in every people
we want.
We needed to pick those who will be a good
story.
David Liberman: So definitely we look at both.
Tim Ferriss: Makes sense.
David Liberman: So in terms of investors in
us, the first investor who supported us, was
—
Daniil Liberman: Basically, he did not allow
us to —
David Liberman: — quit from it.
Daniil Liberman: — back off.
How do you say, back up, and we were almost
ready to say, "Oh…" to give up, and say
like, "Okay, we're not doing this."
And he's like, "No, no, no, guys.
You have to do this.
Please."
David Liberman: Same lesson.
He actually had the similar idea when he was
out of high school in 2001.
He's one who's a general partner of Slow Ventures
—
Daniil Liberman: Too early.
David Liberman: — he invested in us, but
then other prominent names like Marc Andreessen,
or Chris Dixon, or Josh Kushner, they all
—
Daniil Liberman: Also now own —
David Liberman: — invested —
Daniil Liberman: — tiny share of Libermans.
David Liberman: — in Libermans.
But we earned it.
So it did work right away, but we made the
first round, then we proved some results,
and we made the second round.
So, with the startups.
So, when we invest for us, definitely it means
a lot that we want to find really great examples
because all these examples will affect the
future of the idea, and this will help others
to get access to the same type of resources
—
Daniil Liberman: But what's more important
for us, the major thing is whether we believe
in this [inaudible].
If the person will continue building after
failing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that's a big one.
That's a big one because you're not just investing
in one company, or one —
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
We don't invest in one company.
Moreover, we would come, and already did this
through the last year and a half as we investing
in people, we came to people and said like,
"Quit it.
Drop it, and that's not worth your time.
It's not working.
Switch to something new."
David Liberman: You'll never hear about —
Daniil Liberman: You will never ever hear
something like that from the investor who
invested in this particular company.
If I invested in you personally, I am mostly
interested in your success.
And if you are locked yourself —
Tim Ferriss: That's refreshing.
Daniil Liberman: — if you're locked yourself
into something which you're like, "No, no,
no, I've got to do this because this is failure."
It's not failure.
It's an attempt.
60 percent, 70 percent of those attempts are
going to end up with zero, so just move on.
Start the next one.
You'll be successful later.
David Liberman: So with Sam, it's probably
our best relationship with the investors ever.
So because it can be really open in —
Daniil Liberman: Conversation about everything.
David Liberman: — not just showing the good
results, but also showing the things which
are not working, struggles because now we
in a different type of relationship, and we
really like it.
And we actually had challenging experiences
with investors —
Daniil Liberman: Before.
Tim Ferriss: I don't think Sam's going to
take you to any basements.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: It seems unlikely.
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
But not even that.
He's fully supporting us.
David Liberman: In the same when we invest.
So we understand some of the founders, who
invest, they already failed with their current
projects, and they started the new one, and
we were the ones who supported them through
this process.
Daniil Liberman: Some of them are going through
hard times, and we would say, "Go for a sabbatical."
David Liberman: "Go to Vipassana"
Daniil Liberman: "Go to Vipassana.
Take care of yourself.
You need to be super efficient, and you need
to be happy with your own life."
—
David Liberman: Long term, you need to be
efficient.
Daniil Liberman: Long term.
This will score us much more than if you're
like, well destroy yourself right now.
Tim Ferriss: Running out in the next year.
Daniil Liberman: Yeah.
Yeah.
David Liberman: Yes.
And we already have really beautiful examples
when founders this freedom were able to act
the way they wouldn't act —
Daniil Liberman: In the past.
David Liberman: — it already gave some results,
and —
Daniil Liberman: We completely enjoin with
the passes of all the people who we invested
in, and they're all very different, different
stories, different individuals, different
spheres.
It's everywhere from YouTuber to reinventing
quantum physics.
David Liberman: Yes.
With YouTuber, Marina, she's actually really
also awesome example.
She's a founder.
She had the startup, but to create a marketing
vehicle for the startup, she created a YouTube
channel, and then this YouTube channel —
Daniil Liberman: Media empire.
David Liberman: Become a much larger things
than —
Tim Ferriss: Bigger than the startup.
David Liberman: — the startup.
Daniil Liberman: Making like a million plus
—
David Liberman: A year from her network.
Daniil Liberman: But a mortgage, family, kids,
it's all risk, which you wouldn't bet all
of your income to the growth.
Yes, she was growing fast, but as soon as
she got the understanding that she can use
the capital from her future, literally this
is what we are doing.
This is capital from your future.
If you are doing as you are doing right now,
then clearly you're going to have that amount
of money in the future —
David Liberman: So —
Daniil Liberman: You can take part of this
money, which already almost exists into the
present time and use it in order to make your
future even more successful.
Tim Ferriss: So this brings up something that
I wasn't sure we would get to, but I figure
I can bring it up.
Daniil Liberman: Time machine, is it possible?
Tim Ferriss: Well there's the time machine,
but there's also maybe the — and I go back
and forth on how I feel about this, but I
guess you could look to the data, if you have
such data, and there is some it would seem,
but maybe the overfetishizing of suffering,
and how that contributes to success, or the
belief that the more one struggles, the more
likely you are to have outside success because
those make for good stories.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Somebody suffers for their whole
life, and then they show how much they can
persevere, and then they succeed.
But if you look at some of the examples that
you mentioned earlier of the dropout and then
the big company, these are not stories of
abject suffering from the earliest stages
of childhood, generally.
So, would you say, and this is tying it to
what you just said, that by relieving some
of those pressures with the mortgage and the
kids, you're improving the likelihood of a
bigger success later, or somebody could certainly
look at it and say, "Well, she's not going
to be as hungry if..."
Daniil Liberman: So we have lots to say about
this subject.
Tim Ferriss: That's why I'm asking.
Daniil Liberman: A, if we'll look at the most
successful experiment of all times for the
humanity, providing free school education,
free school education for everyone, doesn't
matter whether they're a smartest kid on the
street or not, every kid, gave us more than
any other investment, which we as a humanity,
like infrastructures and stuff know.
Writing free education.
Is this, a capital early on —
David Liberman: It was a controversial idea
like a hundred years ago.
Daniil Liberman: It's an expensive investment
to provide education for every kid.
Expensive investment —
David Liberman: It gives —
Daniil Liberman: And we scored a beautiful
world, gave a lot to us.
So providing a little bit more of the same
can give us unexpected results.
The different perspective is if we'll look
at majority of the unicorns created in United
States and look at who were the founders of
those companies —
Tim Ferriss: And these are companies worth
a billion or more?
Daniil Liberman: Those are companies worth
a billion or more.
What —
David Liberman: A big share of them —
Daniil Liberman: A huge share.
David Liberman: — most of them are from
upper-middle-class families.
They never struggled as us.
They never went through real poverty type
of situation, hunger —
Daniil Liberman: Losing all of their money
in the bank accounts and stuff like this.
David Liberman: — all the stories about
dropouts from high school, from college, they
never had student debt.
Parents paid for their college, and that's
how they afforded to do —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
The other thing that gets left out of those
stories is when you drop out of a fancy school,
they always let you come back, generally.
It's not like you burn the ships behind you.
Daniil Liberman: Exactly.
Exactly.
And then the last one — well, probably not
the last one, but also the last one for me.
Then there it'll go something.
The struggle will come.
It doesn't matter if you have millions of
dollars, you will always be struggling because
you strive to achieve more, and it's challenging,
and it's not necessary that the struggle is
needed, but it will be there.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Daniil Liberman: It doesn't matter if you're
rich or not.
What was this?
"Rich people also cry."
Tim Ferriss: I'm not going to wear that t-shirt
around, but yeah, that's true.
Daniil Liberman: And the challenge comes especially
when you started the startup.
You wanted to succeed, but —
Tim Ferriss: Also human nature is human nature.
Life is suffering.
It's going to find you.
Don't worry.
Daniil Liberman: Sounds scary.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Daniil Liberman: Still here.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly.
David Liberman: But, in general, this argument,
we hear a lot.
That founders should struggle —
Daniil Liberman: We were spoiled.
David Liberman: — and we, personally, struggled
a lot through our founder's path.
We were even no resources in the country where
investments are always considered as a debt.
You need to put as a collateral your house
and things like that compared to San Francisco
where there is no collateral, you can have
a salary.
In our case, we were prohibited to have a
salary as the founders.
How you should survive.
You should have the skin in the game, basically.
Tim Ferriss: No salary.
That's hardcore.
David Liberman: So hardcore.
And if you compare this experience with Silicon
Valley experience, this is a struggle, this
is not a struggle at all.
Daniil Liberman: And then we see all the unicorns
were from a [inaudible].
David Liberman: Yes.
So most of the successful companies would
never exist without venture capital, without
venture capital —
Daniil Liberman: Without this reason —
David Liberman: Venture capital gives the
money in advance.
It's actually not struggling.
Struggling is having the cashflow and building
your bootstrap business.
Most of the companies are not like that because
some levels of achievements —
Daniil Liberman: Requires.
David Liberman: — at least in some areas,
they require this freedom for you to actually
risk and to try things, and that's why we
believe that some struggle is needed.
But we believe that not on the level we have
right now.
Tim Ferriss: You don't have to manufacture
it.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
David Liberman: Yes.
The student loan which stops —
Daniil Liberman: Competition is always struggle,
and there will always be competition.
David Liberman: — but student loan, which
just stops most of young people in United
States from actually taking the risks early
and to achieve more —
Tim Ferriss: And later.
And later, too.
I know people in their thirties who still
haven't paid off their — and I'm not talking
early thirties.
Mid, later thirties, especially if they go
to an extended graduate school or professional
school, they're still paying off student debt.
Daniil Liberman: None of the individuals —
David Liberman: This is unneeded struggle.
This is really unoptimal not needed.
This is artificial struggle because we know
that the subsidized money is paid through
taxes, by people, but it's just spent on a
different stuff.
Tim Ferriss: It goes somewhere else.
David Liberman: So we don't believe in this
idea that the struggle is needed and vice
versa.
We believe that different local maximum, which
would be much higher in terms of the size
of the economy —
Daniil Liberman: Like 10 times higher.
David Liberman: — is in the place where
we remove some of the struggles, especially
those which are artificial and —
Daniil Liberman: Just try to imagine what
it is, 10 times higher.
More electricity, more power, more roads,
more cars, more education, more whatever,
more everything, 10 times more everything.
This is when the abundance is probably likely
to be close to reality.
And that's what we can do in this new local
maximum.
If we just change the perspective on whether
what's more worse to invest in —
David Liberman: Shares or —
Daniil Liberman: — the individual income,
or the undying companies.
The companies are dying.
David Liberman: On average they live actually
less than human beings.
Daniil Liberman: Less human being.
David Liberman: All the statistics is for
people in their potential, but all the regulations
are —
Tim Ferriss: Supporting for companies with
a shorter life span.
David Liberman: Yes.
Daniil Liberman: It's obvious why it's this
way, because in the past we needed this invention
of limited liability companies in order to
remove the personal ownership of personal
[inaudible].
David Liberman: Obligations.
Daniil Liberman: Obligations, individual obligations
over the business.
When your ship is sunk in the sea, now you
owe not only all of your money, your house,
but your family can be taken and enslaved.
We are far away from this world, hundreds
of years away from this world.
David Liberman: So now we can —
Daniil Liberman: Through the innovation of
limited liability, and then the public market,
and this is all innovation in the way how
we see the market, and the way we look at
the market, but we are ready for the new innovation,
and this new innovation can uplift the economy.
Tim Ferriss: So question for you guys.
I'll answer it first too.
So what request would you like to make of
my audience?
So very, very diverse audience across many
countries, many places.
Most of them are interested, on some level,
in technology, not all of them.
Well, let's be honest, all humans are interested
in technology.
They just might not recognize it as technology.
Daniil Liberman: As I said, limited liabilities
company is a technology.
Tim Ferriss: Is a technology.
We all use tools.
That's the reason that Homo sapiens have done
what they've done, good and bad.
But my request for my audience would be to
send me links to some of the biological and
biophysics topics that you both discussed
earlier.
Very interested in all of that, including
quantum effects and potentially bird vision
or olfaction.
All of this is of great interest to me, so
people can shoot those to me on Twitter @tferriss
or elsewhere.
But what requests would you like to make of
my audience, or places you'd like to point
them, anything at all?
David Liberman: Two things.
First, there is a conference about quantum
biology near San Diego in 20th, like 18th
of August.
Daniil Liberman: 18th or 20th.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Here we go.
Look at that.
David Liberman: Best scientists, right now,
are gathering.
And it's still a quite a small group of people,
that's why they're really supportive to each
other.
Daniil Liberman: It's open talk.
David Liberman: They should compete with each
other, but they actually are quite supportive
to each other.
We will be in the conference as well, but
what we would ask is actually, first, to think
who would be those individuals you would invest
in?
Daniil Liberman: Likely, all of us have someone
who will, like this guy, is going to be very
successful.
David Liberman: Second, he sent this information
out to us.
So if you know the brave person, let us know.
Daniil Liberman: You would invest.
You would invest your money and probably —
David Liberman: We all should invest.
Daniil Liberman: — let us know.
And the third one is think that maybe you
should invest in this person as well.
Maybe it's your kid, and you're a parent,
and maybe you should make an agreement, and
actually invest in the first —
David Liberman: Our [inaudible] publicly available
online.
You can all read it and check what's the closest
in there.
You can use this.
Tim Ferriss: And that's libermans.co?
David Liberman: Yes —
Daniil Liberman: Libermans.co.
David Liberman: There is an agreement there.
But, I would say that this is request, so
first think about this people you would invest
in.
Send out the information about them to us.
Tim Ferriss: So what is — just being cognizant
of the fact this is a large audience, so sometimes
not good to give out your private email.
I've had people do that.
I warn them about it.
How should people notify you of these —
Daniil Liberman: We have a form.
Tim Ferriss: You have a form.
Perfect.
Daniil Liberman: Yes, we have a form.
It's humanism.is —
Tim Ferriss: IS.
Daniil Liberman: .is.
Humanism.is.
Tim Ferriss: Humanism.is?
Daniil Liberman: .is.
David Liberman: And also we communicate quite
extensively through Instagram.
We use Instagram not —
Daniil Liberman: Million people will come
—
David Liberman: Usually, we use Instagram
not for pictures, but for larger texts in
some of the ideas.
Tim Ferriss: That's instagram.com/libermans,
also.
Same spelling libermans.co.
David Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Just telling people.
David Liberman: Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
So Instagram, the forum@humanism.is, and people
can find the agreement on —
Daniil Liberman: Libermans.co.
Tim Ferriss: Libermans.co.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: And you have —
Daniil Liberman: What the other ask can be,
if we truly want to see this world happening,
we need to educate the older population and
the investors and the grandmas and grandpas
who actually are shareholders, stakeholders
in the pension funds.
We need to educate those people who actually
own most of the money in the country to gradually
start investing in this type of agreements
to at least check to see what's going to happen
in five, 10 years from now.
If they're going to make more money by investing
in individual income rather than private companies,
public companies, and in this case, we'll
be able to have an experiment, and if it's
a successful experiment, will educate country
and market to shift towards this.
David Liberman: Yes, you can ask your grandma
to look where are the pension money of her
are invested, and to see that probably some
companies will blame for some —
Daniil Liberman: Problems.
David Liberman: — problems in the world.
They can be the investors, but actually, companies
which affect our ecosystem in a bad way, they're
not owned by —
Daniil Liberman: Bankers —
David Liberman: — rich bankers —
Daniil Liberman: — or whatever.
David Liberman: — or rich people.
They actually, most of them, 90 percent owned
by pension funds.
So, if we can educate our previous generations
that they can be a problem.
Daniil Liberman: They're shareholders in the
problem.
David Liberman: They're not the source problem.
Tim Ferriss: Or the shareholders in the future,
and they have to choose —
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: — how their money is influencing
that —
Daniil Liberman: And they can be the shareholders
of the future.
David Liberman: And all of us —
Daniil Liberman: This is the heritage —
David Liberman: — all of us —
Daniil Liberman: — this is the heritage.
They can leave, destroying the planet or actually
switching.
Tim Ferriss: And I would imagine 99.9 percent
of them have no idea —
David Liberman: That they can control it.
Tim Ferriss: — that they have a choice.
Yes.
Daniil Liberman: And they have.
That's the funniest part.
David Liberman: They can log in, and they
can —
Daniil Liberman: They can log in and change.
David Liberman: — change.
Let's sit down with your grandma, maybe look
at their 401K —
Daniil Liberman: Write an email saying, "I
do want some share of my pension funds, my
savings, to be invested in the individual's
corporations."
David Liberman: — or in sustainable companies,
at least.
This education should happen, otherwise there
is this belief that the [inaudible] generation
did everything right, and just the new generation
is fail.
But it's really important to educate that
some decisions, which were made 30 years ago,
affect us a lot today, and some of this effect
can be changed if we change where the money
—
Daniil Liberman: And where is the knowledge
of that.
David Liberman: — invested.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Yeah.
I think a lot of it is a communications problem,
and an education problem, and that net-net,
humans of different generations have more
in common than they have different amongst
them.
But, as you pointed out, sometimes the problems
aren't obvious, and sometimes problems aren't
discussed, and the options aren't discussed.
The fact that I didn't know this until, shockingly,
recently for me, like 10 years ago, that with
retirement accounts you can invest in privately
held companies, and all sorts of other things.
It is an option.
It's just not readily —
Daniil Liberman: Done.
Tim Ferriss: — exploited by most people
because they don't realize that it's on the
menu.
So I'm excited to see what people come up
to.
I'm excited to see what people come up with.
Daniil Liberman: Maybe someone needs to make
a startup which actually offers a solution
for the pensioners to do it easier.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
David Liberman: To just do the sustainable
companies.
That's it.
Tim Ferriss: Some type of interface that makes
it less manual, less one-on-one.
Daniil Liberman: Yeah.
Yeah.
David Liberman: Because right now it is hard.
You need to spend some time to actually set
up your account properly.
But —
Daniil Liberman: It's actually the greatest
opportunity.
We just need all to talk about this.
If you have some challenges believing in this,
A, you can make your own research on trying
to understand whether we are right with our
data and our points of view.
B, you can ask a question in the forum.
You can find a way to reach us out and ask
a question.
So we will explain how we see this until you
believe this is actually the really, really,
really good way of investing your money.
Tim Ferriss: Well, also, this conversation
has raised so many good questions.
One of which is how do you take capital, which
is a currency, it's something that you can
exchange for other things that is currently
locked in a somewhat static form that may
not be generating much positive value in the
world.
And how do you liberate that for other faster
growing, more dynamic sources of value, not
just for the individual, but for the community,
for society?
And I think about that a lot.
It's asset allocation, but on sort of a karmically
considered level, at least at the collective.
David Liberman: And you don't need to spend
the money which you need right now.
It is money which —
Daniil Liberman: You will only get access
like in 30 years from now.
David Liberman: — so we made an experiment
when we joined Snap.
It was first time in our life when we got
401K.
Daniil Liberman: First time in our life employed.
David Liberman: Yes.
Yes.
We never —
Daniil Liberman: So Snap acquired us.
We are employed.
We now have 401K, and the experiment was we
are getting exactly the same salary, exactly
the same savings in the 401K account of both
of us.
David changed everything in his account where
the money is allocated towards more sustainable
companies.
Companies caring about —
David Liberman: Between the Procter & Gambles
and Coca-Colas of the world.
Daniil Liberman: Yeah, exactly, and the Monsantos
of the world, removing them from there and
just shifting the investment towards the companies
which are more sustainable.
Me, I just left everything as it was by default,
provided by Fidelity.
David Liberman: So far, I earned 20,000 more
than Daniil.
Daniil Liberman: 30 percent.
The gross is 30 percent higher than mine.
David Liberman: So, in essence, it's just
[inaudible]
Daniil Liberman: That's the funniest part.
David Liberman: — so if you believe that
other people believe in the same, and that
actually the world is moving in a more sustainable,
clean society, you will win financially, as
well, because if the shift is happening, if
you believe in the shifts, then —
Daniil Liberman: And it should happen, otherwise
we're all going to die.
And because it's happening naturally, logically
it's happening, then it should be no-brainer
that we should invest in the companies which
actually does this because others will lose
in the market game.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Doing right morally doesn't need to mean doing
something that is self-destructive.
You can align the incentives.
Daniil Liberman: Absolutely.
And investing in your kids and your grandkids
is the best thing ever.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
So, I think everybody listening has a good
amount to think about, and they have options
for communicating with you.
They can go to libermans.co to see examples
of the agreements, the types of contracts
that have this participation in future earnings
potential, and outcomes of individuals.
They can go to humanism.is to fill out a form
after they think about which of their friends,
which of their peer group, which of their
circle they would most invest their own savings
into, and they can also consider doing that
themselves with the templates that you provided.
We've got the Instagram book and course for
those interested in exploring coding.
Excuse me.
And the Instagram is instagram.com/libermans.
David, Daniil.
Daniil.
Daniil Liberman: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Thank you so much for taking
the time today.
Daniil Liberman: It was awesome.
Absolute pleasure.
It's a pleasure.
Tim Ferriss: So much fun to traverse so much
ground with you, and for everybody listening,
as per usual, we'll have extensive show notes
linked to all the resources, everything that
was mentioned, and we'll track down a few
things here and there, including links to,
might've been in Wall Street Journal, but
the sports example.
And you can peruse those at your leisure at
tim.blog/podcast.
And, until next time, be a little bit kinder
than is necessary to others, but also to yourself,
and as always, thanks for tuning —